chers collègues l'actualité et
l'activité législative de la commission
des affaires économiques en cette
première année et bien chargée et il
nous revient aujourd'hui d'examiner deux
propositions de loi qui sont inscrites à
l'ordre du jour de la semaine de
l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine d'abord la proposition de loi
visant à lutter contre les arnaques et
les dérives des influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'entends beaucoup de bruit
écoutons-nous chers collègues et puis
ensuite la proposition de la modifier
par le scénarisant à protéger les
logements contre l'occupation inicite où
je suis le rapporteur nous débutons nous
débutons donc nos travaux par la
proposition de loi visant à encadrer
l'activité des influenceurs qui rapporté
par Stéphane Végéta et Arthur de la
porte nous ferons ainsi
œuvre pionnière en encadrant
juridiquement une profession qui émerge
portée par le développement des nouveaux
moyens de communication électronique
cette législation elle permettra certes
de protéger des victimes d'arnaque et je
crois qu'on peut aussi soutenir qu'elle
protégera les influenceurs eux-mêmes en
balisant juridiquement leur champ
d'activité en les éclairant sur ce qui
est autorisé et ce qui est interdit s'il
vous plaît chers collègues je ne
l'entends pas moi-même
plus de 70 sous amendements ont été
déposés si j'en étais tenu aux règles
habituelles de resabilité de notre
commission pour les sous-amendements la
plupart d'entre eux aurait été y
recevables mais j'ai décidé de n’écarter
que les sous-amendements sans aucun lien
avec l'amendement ou contredisant
l'amendement afin que les débats
puissent se tenir en commission et pas
seulement en séance publique ça
permettra d'avoir éventuellement une
rédaction globale des articles de
discuter largement et vraiment plus que
d'habitude des sous amendements à ces
amendements de réécriture comme ça on
peut déjà avoir le débat en commission
plutôt que d'attendre la séance pour
corriger le tiers en contrepartie donc
de cette largesse je n'accepterai plus à
partir de 7 minutes le dépôt de
sous-amendement il restera la
possibilité donc d'amander en séance
publique donc on arrête dès maintenant
le dépôt de sous amendement chers
collègues il nous reste donc au total
173 amendements examinés mais nombre
d'entre eux sont susceptibles de tomber
après l'adoption d'un amendement
proposant une nouvelle rédaction globale
de l'article concerné si nos travaux sur
cette proposition de la sagev avant 13h
et uniquement dans ce cas là nous
débuterions dès ce matin l'examen de la
proposition visant à protéger les
logements contre l'occupation illicite
si ça n'est pas le cas ce texte sera
examiné dans l'après-midi après la CMP
en hémicycle sur la PPL descresize donc
aux alentours de 16h 16h30 dès qu'on a
terminé sur la PPL des groseilles voilà
pour l'organisation de nos travaux et
très cher rapporteur vous avez la parole
monsieur de la porte merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Cora porteur cher
Stéphane et chers collègues
c'est maintenant qu'il ne faut rien
lâcher
ces mots-là ce sont ceux de Seb la frite
3,1 million d'abonnés sur Twitter
ces paroles d'influenceurs comme celle
de Lena situation 4 millions d'abonnés
sur Instagram ou inoxtag 2,7 millions
sur Twitter qui s'intéresse par ailleurs
ces influenceurs particulièrement ces
derniers jours à la politique il nous
engage à agir agir notamment dans cette
période parsemée de troubles politiques
pour réguler un lieu d'influence dont la
politique c'est peut-être trop longtemps
des intéressés aujourd'hui néanmoins les
initiatives pour réguler la jungle de
l'influence foisonne il était temps de
les faire converger c'est dans cette
perspective que j'avais déposé un texte
mais que j'ai accepté de retirer pour
reprendre le travail et construire ce
que mon collègue Végéta appelle une
bulle de paix que nous construisons
singulièrement autour de ce texte
transpartisan et cette bulle de paix
était nécessaire
parce que ces jeunes femmes et c'est
jeunes hommes pour la plupart ils ont
une importance particulière dans le
quotidien des Français mais on a aussi
pu observer de la part d'une minorité
d'entre eux des dérives majeures et nous
y reviendrons c'est important elle se
traduit donc par l'image aussi que
coffre notre Parlement aujourd'hui ce
caractère uni et je voudrais dire
exceptionnel mais j'espère que le
Parlement se saisissant de nouveau de sa
force nous serons amenés à reproduire ce
genre d'initiative mais qui fait que
nous allons pouvoir collectivement faire
évoluer notre droit ceci donc fier
aujourd'hui de vous présenter avec mon
collègue volgéta un texte qui répond à
un des enjeux de notre époque un enjeu
parfois vu de loin par ses entre nous
mais qui aussi a mobiliser beaucoup
d'autres que je tiens à saluer en notre
nom à tous les deux je veux remercier
tous les députés qui se sont engagés
dans le groupe de travail transpartisans
que nous avons lancé depuis maintenant
deux mois pour co-construire les
amendements de consensus que nous vous
présenterons tout à l'heure donc dans ce
texte qui était initialement bip artisan
mais que nous avons élargi à l'ensemble
des groupes de l'arc républicain
répond donc et je le disais à une
problématique comment lutter
efficacement contre les trop nombreuses
dérives des influenceurs sur les réseaux
sociaux nous en avons eu hier soir pour
celles et ceux qui étaient présents des
témoignages concrets et différents les
exemples s'accumulent Marc et n'a des
blattas avec les escroqueries aux crypto
monnaie Julien tanti qui faisait la
promotion de maillot contrefaits et
notre collègue Blancher s'impliquera sur
ce sujet Maeva gainame qui a fait la
promotion d'objets vendus sur des sites
dépourvus de conditions générales de
vente ou de cosmétiques non conformes
aux droits de l'Union Européen et qui
donne par exemple des plaques urticantes
mais là Jasmine qui vend la pratique
illégale de la médecine ou Kevin Guedj
qui a fait la promotion du trading ces
influenceurs aux millions d'abonnés ne
sont que la partie immergée de l'iceberg
la partie visible des dérives mais aussi
d'autres abus ont pu être constatés chez
le plus petit des micros ou des
nano-influenceurs celles et ceux qui
n'ont quelques centaines ou milliers
d'abonnés mais dont les taux de
conversion vers une pratique ou une
dérive moins nacte de consommation son
diablement efficaces ce texte vient donc
apporter des fondations à l'édifice de
la régulation d'un milieu qui a
multiplié les dérives en apparence en
toute impunité c'est impunité est finie
et ce texte répond aussi à une autre
problématique comment ne pas stigmatiser
les créateurs de contenu et vous les
évoquez monsieur le Président et nous en
avons discuté hier soir avec les
influenceurs invités et c'est centaines
ces milliers ces dizaines de milliers
d'influenceurs qui font leur travail
correctement avec une éthique qui leur
tient à cœur vous savez celles et ceux
que j'ai mentionné au début de mon
intervention mais aussi ce que nous
avons reçu hier soir comme major
movement crazy Sally ou encore Squeezie
pour le plus connu d'entre nous c'est
autant de femmes et d'hommes talentueux
qui produisent du divertissement ou des
contenus pédagogiques qui touchent des
millions de Françaises et de français et
nous ne pouvons nous permettre d'avoir
un jugement moral sur l'ensemble de
cette activité
super collaborateurs et puis nous les
oublions pas et nous pensons beaucoup
par eux les lanceurs d'alerte qu'ils ont
accompagnés les collectifs Audrey Kumba
Chris slim que nous avons reçu hier ou
enfin pour ma part ça me dira qui m'a
aussi permis d'accéder à un certain
d'influenceurs et à une communauté qui
s'intéresse à ce sujet maintenant chers
Stéphane je vous laisse la parole la
cime se rapporter monsieur Vegeta
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues chers Cora porteur chez Arthur
dans les circonstances actuelles
certains pourraient penser que notre
Assemblée nationale n'est plus adaptée
au monde d'aujourd'hui trop lente trop
partisane trop téléguidé trop déconnecté
pourtant aujourd'hui membre de la
majorité et soutient assumé du président
de la République je siège en tant que
corps-à-porteur aux côtés de mon
collègue Arthur Delaporte du groupe
socialiste dupes chacun connaît nos
différences et celles de nos groupes
respectifs sur bien d'autres sujets
notamment ceux qui ont fait vibrer
l'hémicycle ces dernières semaines et
que je ne mentionnerai pas ici pour
respecter l'esprit de la bulle de paix
que tu que vous avez mentionné chez
Arthur et dans laquelle nous avons
décidé d'un commun accord de travailler
comme bien d'autres parlementaires sur
notre continent nous avons su créer une
passerelle entre nos groupes nous avons
négocié les points de convergence en
faisant de notre mieux pour ignorer les
postures idéologiques pour peu à peu
tenter d'atteindre l'objectif avancer
vers le consensus qui je l'espère va se
matérialiser ce matin
pour ce faire il fallait notamment se
faire confiance s'écouter et oser se
dire les choses en face merci donc chers
corps rapporteur d'avoir saisi cette
main tendue ma main tendue et d'avoir
cru en la ça sincérité de ma démarche
j'espère que vous ne le regretterez pas
je profite de cette occasion pour moi
aussi remercier notamment nos deux
responsables de textes violet spielbou
et Dominique Pottier avec qui j'aimerais
juste travailler je remercie aussi bien
sûr et je m'associe remerciement du
corps à porteur nous collaborateurs
Gauthier Léopold ainsi que les
administrateurs impliqués en premier
lieu Benjamin Douchy
pour ce texte nous avons effectivement
voulu surmonter nos différences pourquoi
parce que c'est dans l'intérêt de ces
assemblées je le pense sincèrement mais
surtout parce que c'est dans l'intérêt
des Français
parce que c'est dans l'intérêt des
nombreuses victimes des dérives
auxquelles nous souhaitons mettre fin
victimes que nous avons pu auditionner
et écouter tout au long de ce processus
victime qui nous ont permis de nous
saisir de ce sujet et que nous avons
notamment écouté hier soir lors d'une
audition publique et qui ont permis de
confirmer et réaffirmer nos convictions
mais aussi parce que c'est l'intérêt de
l'immense majorité des influenceurs et
créateurs d'un contenu
je parle de cette immense majorité celle
qui est un comportement responsable
respectueux des règles une majorité
d'influenceurs et de créateurs de
contenus qui ne méritent pas de voir son
image polluée par une minorité
irresponsable ou carrément malhonnête
mais aussi une majorité d'influenceurs
qui méritent également d'exercer son
activité d'influence commerciale dans un
cadre clarifié
je me réjouis donc de vous proposer
aujourd'hui à côté d'Arthur Delaporte
notre proposition de loi dans un format
peut-être
audacieux avec un travail collectif qui
nous a amené parfois à improviser et qui
va nous amener à le faire ce matin
encore en tout cas un format original et
qui prouve que la représentation
nationale a du ressort
même si elle évidence nous n'avons pas
inventé le transpartisanisme nous
espérons que ce processus puisse
inspirer à l'avenir certains d'entre
nous issus du groupe différents mais
entre lesquels le compromis n'est pas
impossible
pour porter des textes différents et des
textes ensemble c'est notamment ainsi
que nous parviendrons à rester les
parlementaires efficaces dans les années
à venir en dépit des configurations
actuelles de notre vie politique
merci beaucoup messieurs les rapporteurs
je vous propose qu'on passe aux orateurs
de
groupe à moi que Monsieur Delaporte vous
aviez autre chose à dire
merci monsieur le Président c'était pour
préciser la structure du texte que nous
allons vous proposer présenter
aujourd'hui qui vise à traiter
finalement les grands sujets qui font
écho aux différents aspects que nous
avons pu mentionné dans nos
interventions luminaires avec Stéphane
Végéta savoir la responsabilisation et
la sanction nous avons
finalement décidé et choisi de vous
présenter des amendements de réécriture
notamment sur l'article premier pour
scinder les différents sujets qui le
contenaient notamment le premier article
un article qui vise à définir
l'influence commerciale et que nous
avons retravaillé collectivement pour
faire pour le faire évoluer faire
évoluer cette définition vers la notion
d'activité de l'influence commerciale la
pratique de l'influence commerciale nous
vous proposerons ensuite un article
additionnel après l'article premier qui
rappelle rat les droits généraux et les
devoirs des influenceurs et notamment
celui de respecter les différents cadres
légaux notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
et je pense à la loi Eva nous
proposerons ensuite un article article
premier de terre qui vise lui à réguler
et à sanctionner de façon plus effective
un certain nombre de promotion en raison
des intérêts d'ordre public ou de
préservation de la santé publique et
nous y reviendrons ça me donne
l'occasion de le dire mais nous y
reviendrons je pense aussi les postes
relatifs à la chirurgie esthétique les
investissements risqués des inscriptions
à des formations bidon doivent être
bannis de l'influence commerciale nous
avons eu hier eu des témoignages
édifiants sur les conséquences sur la
vie des Françaises et des Français il
s'agit donc de préserver et de protéger
les consommateurs et notamment les
publics vulnérables beaucoup de
personnes beaucoup de jeunes suivent ces
personnes sur les fragiles personne
fragiles économiquement qui font
confiance qui créent un lien spécial ou
pense créer un lien spécial et peuvent
tomber dans des pièges en dépensant
perdant des sommes d'argent considérable
ou en malmenant leur santé enfin nous
allons proposer également des
amendements de réécriture sur la
question de la publicité nous faisons
évoluer la notion de bandeau notamment
contraignante vers plutôt un régime de
mention obligatoire et nous renvoyons
aussi au pouvoir réglementaire pour
avoir une certaine souplesse dans la
mise en place de ces régulations
élaborer des mécanismes d'exception et
éviter au mieux les effets de bord les
règles qui seront issues de cette
proposition de loi nous permettront donc
d'avoir une définition pour armer la
base juridique qui nous permettra aussi
dans un temps court avec la navette la
CMP de continuer à travailler ses
définitions mais nous pensons ici vous
fournir une première base qui est le
fruit d'un consensus je laisse Stéphane
Vegeta préciser les dispositions des
autres articles bien sur les autres
articles monsieur Vegeta
merci donc précisé que le texte conjoint
était à évolué suite à nous rencontre
informel et à nos auditions officielles
que nous avons été également associés au
table ronde de Bercy et que nous avons
lu avec attention les conclusions de la
consultation publique initiée par Bruno
Le Maire à laquelle des dizaines de
milliers de Françaises et de français au
contribués et que comme résultat les
grands objectifs grands principes
objectifs que poursuit ce texte et que
nous poursuivons sont les suivants ne
plus permettre que l'influence
commerciale soit une manière de
contourner les règles
mettre fin à l'ambiguïté parfois
savamment entretenu quant à la
légitimité ou à l'applicabilité de
certaines lois à l'influence commerciale
compléter de manière très ciblée
certaines des restrictions actuelles
n'ont pas pour vouloir faire la morale
mais quand nous estimons que ces
restrictions ne garantissent pas
suffisamment la défense de la santé
publique et celle des droits des
consommateurs ou des investisseurs
encadrer une activité qui devient
prépondérante et très légitime dans les
stratégies marketing de nos entreprises
responsabiliser toutes les parties
prenantes d'un influence commerciale
créateur de contenu apporteur d'affaires
annonceur et plateformes et tout cela
bien sûr sans vouloir entraver en aucun
cas la liberté d'expression ni faire
peser des contraintes injustifiées sur
les secteurs économiques concernés
en ce qui concerne l'examen du texte
aujourd'hui je couvrirai personnellement
les articles 2 à 5 l'article 2 vient
définir le statut d'agent d'influenceur
et rend notamment obligatoire
l'établissement d'un contrat écrit entre
l'influenceur et l'annonceur où son
agent ou intermédiaire ou à porteur
d'affaires les articles 3 et 4 quant à
eux vissent à s'assurer de la
responsabilisation des plateformes
numériques en reprenant des éléments du
règlement européen sur les services
numériques également appelés DSA
et enfin avec toujours à l'esprit que
nous légiférons pour l'avenir et donc en
pensant à notre jeunesse nous interrons
à travers l'article 5 la notion de
sensibilisation sensibilisation contre
les risques d'ordre commercial dans la
formation au risque numérique dispensés
dans les établissements scolaires et
voter dans le cadre de la PJL renforçant
les principes de la République l'an
dernier je vous remercie
bien merci messieurs le rapporteur pas
d'autres éléments ajoutés on peut passer
aux orateurs groupes je vous propose
donc de passer aux orateurs de groupe et
on va commencer tout de suite donc vous
connaissez le principe pour celles et
ceux qui nous rejoignent je les
réexplique c'est 4 minutes
d'intervention 3 pour vous et
éventuellement une de réponse des
rapports donc vous pouvez faire
question-Réponses avec les rapporteurs
vous pouvez faire une intervention
longue de 2 à 3 minutes maximum puis
ensuite on se laisse une petite minute
de réponse si les rapporteurs le
souhaitent et puis ensuite on passe à
l'orateur suivant je vous propose de
commenter avec Madame violette spielbout
du groupe Renaissance c'est à vous merci
monsieur le Président messieurs les
cours à porteurs mes chers collègues
nous voilà aujourd'hui réunis pour
parler d'un sujet éminemment attendu par
nos jeunes mais pas que par l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et consommateurs il
suffit d'être un utilisateur régulier
des réseaux sociaux ou des plateformes
comme youtube pour être régulièrement
alerté par les dérives de l'influence en
ligne nous sommes là aujourd'hui pour
éviter que de nouvelles personnes soient
victimes de placement fin frauduleux de
produits de blanchiment dentaires
dangereux ou d'escroquerie au compte
formation professionnelle bien trop
souvent par des influenceurs à très
forte notoriété
issues de la télé-réalité alors comme
tout le monde le sait au départ c'est
une promesse de beauté éternelle de
pilules miracle pour guérir le cancer
d'injections à moins 50%, ou encore d'un
placement financier hasardeux à taux
positif à 15% par jour sur les six
prochains mois pour les annonceurs et
les marques c'est prescripteur 2.0 à
forte notoriété sont les clients idéaux
pour faire la promotion de leurs
produits et développer leur profit mais
derrière les belles promesses de ces
vendeurs de rêves gare au Mirage et au
désillusions en cascade les victimes
sont vulnérables naïf parfois elles font
confiance à leurs idoles heureusement
pour les défendre et les protéger de
nombreux collectifs se sont organisés
depuis quelques années nous les avons
reçues avec beaucoup d'attention et
d'écoute hier soir le gouvernement a
aussi pris en considération cette
urgence et a mis en place un site signal
conso.gouv.fr service public pour les
consommateurs rattachés à la DGCCRF dont
la mission s'articule autour de la
régulation concurrentielle des marchés
la protection économique des
consommateurs et leur sécurité une
grande consultation a été menée par
Bruno Le Maire pour nourrir notre
proposition de loi le groupe des députés
Renaissance entend ses enjeux et
souhaite par cette proposition alertée
et protégée pour que nos enfants mais
aussi les moins jeunes d'entre nous ne
se fassent plus avoir pour que nul ne
soit au-dessus des lois pour qu'aucun
influenceur ne puisse plus dire je ne
savais pas pour qu'il n'y ait plus
d'amende type Nabilla ou de condamnation
comme celui du couple Blatta mais
surtout derrière eux plus de victimes
des abusées notre proposition se base
certes sur les dérives de la promotion
agressive de produits et de pratiques
interdites mais cette préoccupation ne
doit pas masquer que heureusement la
majorité des influenceurs respecte les
règles en vigueur et attachent une forte
importance aux pratiques éthiques et
responsables en aucun cette proposition
de loi n'a de vocation à punir les
créateurs de contenu et les agences qui
véhiculent très souvent de belles
valeurs autour du jeûne public ils sont
également créateurs d'emploi et sont des
modèles pour notre jeunesse c'est
notamment tout le sens d'un amendement
que j'aurai l'occasion de porter ce
matin qui vise à instaurer un label
national relations influenceurs
responsable pour garantir la
transparence des pratiques et le respect
de la réglementation nous nous
préoccuperons aussi dans ce texte de
protéger davantage les relations
existantes entre les créateurs de
contenu et les agents ou annonceurs et
les droits de l'influenceur mes chers
collègues nous avons ce matin une
responsabilité et une chance inouïe de
pouvoir protéger les victimes et
structurer la nouvelle filière de
l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux ou
sur les plateformes merci à nos deux
corps apporteurs Stéphane vogeta et
Arthur de Laporte d'agir si concrètement
après plus de 10 ans de vie de juridique
avec ces très belles propositions de loi
transpartisanes que le groupe
Renaissance soutient et viendra enrichir
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup alors sur le chrono
j'avais pas lancé le chrono donc ne vous
inquiétez pas voilà
erreur de lancement de chrono mais elle
coule pas vous souhaitez prendre une
minute de réponse ou pas allez-y
monsieur Bogota je vais très bref merci
merci
j'ai oublié de mettre en compte je vous
assure excusez-nous
je vous remercie pour je vous remercie
pour votre intervention simplement
confirmer effectivement que que ce
travail ce travail collectif impliqué
également un travail du côté du
gouvernement et notamment des ministères
de Bercy ministère de Bruno Le Maire
d'Olivia Grégoire et de Jean-Noël
barreau et que cette loi s'inscrit dans
un dans un dans un cadre de conclusion
qui inclueront notamment des mesures
non législatives donc plutôt d'ordre
réglementaire qui seront annoncés
notamment par Bruno Le Maire ce vendredi
et qui devront donc être comprise dans
un le travail d'ensemble et une volonté
d'ensemble de structuration du secteur
et qui structuration qui pourra
notamment s'appuyer sur des initiatives
que nous avons pu notamment débattre
avec avec la PPP l'Autorité de
régulation professionnelle de la
publicité notamment par exemple la mise
en place d'un certificat de l'influence
responsable donc il y a effectivement en
parallèle tout un travail de de
régulation d'autorégulation et
d'organisation du secteur que nous
soutenons et qui pour qui je l'espère
cette loi viendra ajouter un cadre
législatif nécessaire et
utile merci
bien je vous propose de continuer sur
les orateurs de groupe chez Madame
Christine en grande groupe rassemblement
national c'est à vous merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
les rapporteurs chers collègues je ne
vais pas répéter que nous pensons qu'une
telle proposition de loi devrait être
discutée en étant plus appropriés du
point de vue politique et économique
nous l'avions déjà dit et surtout au vu
des difficultés rencontrées par nos
entreprises actuellement par cohérence
je ne vais pas non plus m'attarder sur
le caractère rébarbatif de certaines
propositions du premier article que nous
avions déjà longuement critiqué lors de
l'examen de la proposition en février
aujourd'hui j'aimerais plutôt que l'on
se penche sur les nouveautés de cette
proposition en commençant par saluer
cette tentative visant à soumettre droit
français les influenceurs installés à
l'étranger cette proposition s'inscrit
dans l'air du temps le début de la fin
du village global ou une poignée de
privilégiés à patrides peuvent se
défaire de toute contrainte légale pour
autant cette tentative aussi louable
soit-elle et condamnée dès le départ à
rester un vœu pieux faute de moyens
coercitifs concrets je m'explique vous
dites que les influenceurs qui proposent
du contenu à destination de la
population française doivent être
représentés légalement en France afin
qu'ils soient indirectement soumis à
notre droit par l'intermédiaire de leur
représentants très bien maintenant que
proposez-vous pour les contraindre à
désigner ce représentant légal par
conséquent que changera cette
proposition de loi pour les influenceurs
de demain pas grand chose pour ceux qui
assument de piétiner le droit français
tant qu'ils ne daigneront pas se faire
représenter rien ne pourra leur arriver
des solutions concrètes existent
pourtant mais il faut taper là où ça
fait mal en entachant la réputation des
fraudeurs et en limitant l'audience de
leur publicité c'est ce que nous allons
vous proposer dans les amendements qui
vont suivre merci
ce que vous souhaitez réagir c'est de la
porte
bon c'était vous avez considéré notre
texte de réberbatif nous on considère au
contraire qu'il est extrêmement positif
qui déploie une activité sur un certain
nombre de pans aujourd'hui du droit qui
n'étaient pas ou qui appeler une
régulation vous avez dit le texte ne
changera pas grand-chose au contraire
qu'il peut changer beaucoup déjà en
définissant ce dont on ne parle pas et
voyez je reste calme parce que voilà je
pense que on a réussi à construire cette
bulle de paix mais je considère que
voilà il y a un seul groupe qui fait
preuve d'agressivité c'est c'est le
vôtre voilà bien merci Monsieur comme on
avait le
alors attendez comme il y a un peu de
temps vous aviez une question
bien sûr
alors
la réponse allez-y me suis Végéta voilà
écoutez moi je suis extrêmement fier
d'être un député qui représente les
Français de l'étranger Français de
l'étranger qui dans leur immense
majorité sont des Français qui
s'expriment qui s'expatrient qui partent
pour de belles raisons et qui ne le font
certainement pas pour essayer d'éviter
la loi ou d'éviter l'impôt
dans ce cadre là d'abord je déplore
évidemment la qualification de
privilégier la patrie qu'il est beaucoup
trop générique et qui démontre la
capacité de certaines brebis galeuses
effectivement à contaminer l'image de
certains c'est le cas pour les
influenceurs responsables que nous avons
mentionné qui malheureusement sont sont
sont
mal représentés par par ces quelques
brevés gazeuses en l'occurrence nous
avons notre texte propose des solutions
concrètes pour que personne ne puisse
mettre en place de stratégie d'évitement
de la loi en s'éloignant du territoire
de la France et de l'Europe qui est une
Europe qui je le rappelle nous protège
également ce sera notamment le cas avec
la mention obligatoire au sein du
obligatoire de l'application du droit
français
assez assez opérations de promotion
commerciale et ce sera également le cas
à travers la disposition que nous
proposons à vous tous chers collègues
qui consiste à là encore à mettre en
place l'obligation de la d'une police
d'assurance de responsabilité civile
pour ces personnes qui évoluent hors du
territoire européen et dans les
activités pourraient provoquer des
dommages auprès de consommateurs qui eux
sont sur le territoire français dommage
qui pourrait donc dans ce cas être
couvert notamment par cette police de
responsabilité civile merci beaucoup
j'ai madame abomangoli pour le groupe
LFI c'est à vous
monsieur le Président mais c'est le
rapporteur mes recherches collègues cela
faisait trop longtemps que les victimes
d'arnaque d'influenceurs sur les réseaux
sociaux attendent des actes nous avions
eu droit il y a une vidéo du ministre
d'économie des finances appelant les
influenceurs à la responsabilité et
manifestement ça n'avait pas été
suffisant malgré la création du site
signal conso c'est la raison pour
laquelle avec mes collègues François
pikman mais aussi Aurélien attaché nous
avions lancé des pistes à travers deux
propositions de loi le travail de ma
collègue Ségolène agneau à mes côtés
pour la protection des mineurs vient
idéalement compléter notre réflexion
collective soulignons que de nombreuses
associations de victimes des collectifs
et de nombreux lanceurs d'alerte mais
aussi des internautes étaient mobilisés
jusque là mais bien seul on peut citer
le collectif avis que vous avez reçu vos
stars en réalité ou encore signal
arnaque et de nombreux internautes
anonymes qui sont fortement mobilisés
sur les réseaux sociaux et que cela
plaise ou non l'entrée en scène du
rapport Booba méthode certes contestée à
aider à la prise et contestable
va aider à la prise de conscience
médiatique et le sujet n'est pas anodin
comme on a pu l'entendre ici crypto
monnaie dropshipping arnaque au CPF
produit cosmétiques dangereux ou trading
au bout des arnaques et des dérives il y
a parfois de la précarité et de la mise
en danger physique ou psychologique je
n'oublie pas qu'il s'agit de réguler une
activité qui attire pas question j'étais
la pire au créateur de contenu comme
vous l'avez rappelé mais il y a un fort
rejet éthique dans cette démarche de
régulation le secteur de l'influence
commerciale ne doit pas devenir synonyme
d'argent facile sur le dos des
consommateurs mais disons-le clairement
chers collègues bon nombre de pratiques
commerciales illégales et bon nombre
d'excroqueries en ligne tombe déjà sous
le coup de la loi notre démarche
consiste donc davantage à approfondir le
cadre réglementaire et législatif et à
démasquer les responsables dans un
contexte spécifique émouvant des réseaux
sociaux il faut pointer également le
rôle des plateformes et le manque de
moyens systémique de l'État surtout
rappelons-le ce n'est pas plateforme
seul en tant qu'entreprise privée de
fixer des normes d'intérêt général
l'application totale de la justice et
d'admintration de l'État et la clim
aucun signalement n'aura jamais la force
de la chose contrôlée et jugée le marché
de l'influence a été multiplié par 10
entre 2016 et aujourd'hui pour atteindre
les 16 milliards d'euros quel
renforcement des moyens de l'État en
parallèle très peu à notre à notre avis
les chartes les guides et les labels de
bonne pratique n'engagent que celles et
ceux qui croient notre triptyque est
donc le suivant protection des victimes
responsabilisation des plateformes
répression des fraudes de nombreuses
mesures de ce texte vont dans le bon
sens cependant il apparaît que les
moyens d'agir et de défendre de se
défendre pour les citoyens doivent être
musclés il y va de la crédibilité tous
les acteurs ce sera le sens de nous
amendements à ce stade nous savons pas
quels seront les engagements du
ministère de l'Économie des Finances
dont les annonces ont été reportées de
ces annonces dépendent la portée réelle
de ce texte qui est manifestement les
annonces du ministre seront plutôt axées
sur la structure de la filière on attend
beaucoup nous du coup du point de vue
des droits des consommateurs et de la
défense des victimes c'est donc à
l'issue du parcours démocratique de
cette proposition de loi que nous nous
prononcerons définitivement je vous
remercie pour finir pour ce travail
transpartisan qui a vraiment été très
très inclusif merci beaucoup une
réaction monsieur les rapporteurs
rapides monsieur de la porte merci chers
collègues pour vos propos et pour saluer
ce caractère inclusif de notre travail
vous avez évoqué en effet les lanceurs
d'alerte et les victimes le rôle de
certains et en particulier du rappeur
Booba c'est vrai qui a été reconnu par
la presse
bon il s'agit ici en effet de réguler
une activité qui a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de campagne et beaucoup
d'articles en fait ces derniers temps et
donc nous nous inscrivons dans le moment
présent et nous espérons par ailleurs et
ça sera l'occasion de le dire que le
texte qui sera voté par notre assemblée
sera un texte pionnier en la matière en
Europe ou les différents pays sont
confrontés au même problématiques que
nous et cherche en même temps en
tâtonnant à réguler ce secteur qui voilà
merci beaucoup nous passons à Madame
dubymuller pour le groupe les
républicain c'était vous merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur les Cora porteurs
je tiens tout d'abord à saluer les
récentes initiatives législatives visant
à apporter davantage de régulation dans
le secteur de l'influence et qui
s'effectue en parallèle de la grande
consultation publique lancée par Bruno
Le Maire en effet il est urgent d'agir
comme la montrer l'étude accablante de
la direction générale de la concurrence
de la consommation et de la répression
des fraudes celle-ci a montré que sur la
soixantaine d'influenceurs et agences
qu'elle a ciblé depuis 2021 60% ne
respectait pas la réglementation sur la
publicité et les droits des
consommateurs plus grave parmi eux
certains ont trompé sciemment le
consommateur en matière de santé d'abord
nombre d'influenceurs ont fait la
promotion d'injection réalisée par des
esthéticiens et non pas des
professionnelles de santé de produits
miracles soi-disant capables de faire
maigrir ou pire de guérir des cancers
outre la beauté et la santé le CPF les
influenceurs ont investi le secteur
financier
ils sont nombreux à vendre des services
financiers risqués tels que les trading
de crypto monnaie ou faire la promotion
de Paris aux résultats très aléatoires
je pense notamment aux candidates
télé-réalité Julien Berthe qui réalise
des vidéos de promotion de trading en
promettant à ces followers d'avoir 100%
de chance de gagner de l'argent avec lui
celui-ci utilise en effet un robot de
trading un outil automatisé qui ne
nécessite aucune intervention humaine
pour prendre les positions sur les
marchés des sanctions sont certes
prononcées mais elle reste encore trop
rare ainsi la célèbre influenceuse
Nabilla Benattia Vergara a été condamné
l'été dernier à payer une amende de
20000 euros pour des pratiques
commerciales trompeuses relatives à la
promotion sur le réseau social snapchat
d'un site de formation au trading en
ligne si l'on peut se féliciter que ces
arnaques soient de plus en plus
dénoncées indéniablement ces
influenceurs majoritairement domiciliées
à Dubaï ont profité des zones grises
qu'il convient de clarifier il faut
d'ailleurs distinguer les influenceurs
issus de la en réalité comme Mark Blatta
des autres c'est pourquoi cette
proposition de loi apporte un cadre
juridique nécessaire à la protection des
consommateurs d'autant qu'aujourd'hui
les marques utilisent beaucoup de
créateurs de contenu et désertent les
médias traditionnels afin d'éviter
l'abus de confiance de la part des
influenceurs auprès de leur communauté
souvent composées en grande partie de
mineurs facilement influençable le texte
créé et renforce un appareil juridique
qui pourra à la fois responsabiliser et
sanctionner le cas échéant tous les
influenceurs mais aussi leurs agences
les annonceurs ainsi que les plateformes
de diffusion c'est pourquoi il est
important de responsabiliser l'ensemble
de l'écosystème les influenceurs les
agents et les plateformes et celles-ci
ont d'ailleurs commencé à agir puisque
devant la multiplication des plaintes
contre les influx-volleurs meta maison
mère de Facebook et Instagram a fermé
des comptes des personnes incriminées
mais il faut néanmoins aller plus loin
en instaurant une véritable régulation
et en les obligeant à bloquer les
contenus publicitaires définis comme
mensonges il s'agit également d'envoyer
un message fort à notre jeunesse qui
peut être fasciné par le bling BL cet
argent semble facilement gagner par les
influenceurs mais il n'est pas permis de
tout faire avec un smartphone et il est
de notre devoir de protéger les victimes
de ses abus qui sont souvent des publics
fragiles ou des jeunes ce texte
permettra donc de rétablir la confiance
dans le secteur et pour toutes ces
raisons les républicains soutiendront le
texte dans un esprit de consensus et
nous espérons évidemment que vous
soutiendrez un certain nombre des
amendements que nous avions déposés
merci beaucoup une réaction sur le
rapporteur sur Vegeta oui simplement
pour abonder dans votre dans votre
direction
l'enjeu est réel et il y a des pertes
réelles subissent par les subies par les
consommateurs et les investisseurs nous
savons très bien que dans le monde réel
des conseils d'investissement sont
extrêmement encadrés et c'est
encadrement est extrêmement respecté par
tous les acteurs et notamment les
conseils financiers en l'occurrence il
se trouve que on ne peut que constater
que trop souvent les les conseils
financiers naviguer sur les réseaux
sociaux contourne ces règles ne
dénoncent aucune des règles de prudence
de base ne donne aucun des
avertissements nécessaires pour
permettre à des publics parfois peu
formés de de de filtrer ces messages et
donc il est nécessaire d'agir et nous
agissons merci beaucoup nous passons
donc à Madame Louise Morel du groupe
modem c'est à vous merci
les rapporteurs chers collègues
l'avènement d'Internet a permis la
naissance du plus grand réseau que
l'humanité a jamais connu
interconnectant informatiquement parlant
entre des milliards d'individus tous
nous faisons partie de ces réseaux qui
sont dissociaux définis comme un
agencement de lien entre des individus
des organisations qui constituent un
groupement qui a un sens famille
collègue groupe d'amis communauté
naturellement ces réseaux se sont
étendus à Internet constituant de
véritables réseaux sociaux en ligne et
le développement de ces réseaux sociaux
en ligne a permis l'émergence d'un
nouveau modèle social économique voire
politique fondée sur l'influence de nos
pères et l'appréciation collective ces
utilisateurs qui regroupent des milliers
voire des millions d'abonnés ont acquis
le statut intrinsèque d'influenceurs en
ce qu'ils sont capables de modifier en
profondeur les habitudes de consommation
de leurs abonnés cette capacité à
toucher un large public attire de plus
en plus les entreprises et les marques
qui se tournent vers ces nouveaux
vecteurs de publicité marketing la
plupart des influenceurs cela a été
rappelé sont d'abord et avant tout des
réalisateur de contenu artistique ou des
divertissements vidéo ludiques sur des
plateformes comme youtube Tik Tok ou
encore twitch et qui font la promotion
de produits pour financer leurs autres
activités d'autres influenceurs
issus de la téléréalité notamment font
des réseaux sociaux leur principal
activités et sources de revenus au total
nous comptons en France 150 000
influenceurs tout profil confondus en
2023 ainsi l'influence commerciale sur
les réseaux sociaux fait désormais
partie intégrante de notre quotidien au
même titre que les spots publicitaires à
la télévision ou les panneaux
publicitaires dans la rue et
sociologiquement ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est qu'au moment de l'achat
d'un produit nous sommes influencés par
un certain nombre de facteurs extérieurs
publicités avis en ligne ou encore ceux
de nos amis et le lien qui unit
influenceurs et les abonnés repose non
seulement sur la confiance mais aussi
sur l'adhésion à des valeurs communes le
sentiment d'appartenance à un groupe en
parallèle on a plusieurs biais cognitifs
comme le billet de conformité qui altère
notre capacité à raisonner correctement
sur les réseaux de cette manière les
influenceurs regroupent tous les
facteurs d'influence à la fois ce qui
rend leur impact sur les comportements
d'achat de leurs abonnés très importants
au total le marché de l'influence est
estimé à 16,4 milliards de dollars dans
le monde en 2022 et cette manne
financière attire les vautours pratique
commerciale trompeuses et scroquerie
arnaque en France les affaires
impliquant des influenceurs se
multiplient les scandales et les fraudes
foisonnent et face au vide juridique en
tourant le marché de l'influence les
victimes sont bien souvent démunies
c'est la raison pour laquelle le groupe
démocrate ça lui vivement cette
proposition de loi qui a vocation
encadré le statut d'influenceurs d'une
part et à protéger les utilisateurs des
dérives potentiels d'hôtes d'autre part
nous nous réjouissons sincèrement des
débats qui s'ouvrent nombreux sur ce
sujet je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
végétalisé
je vous remercie pour vos propos très
brièvement je pense que nous sommes
totalement alignés avec avec vos PROFOS
et la reconnaissance d'une nécessité
d'agir au niveau législatif pour
encadrer cette activité qui n'est pas
encore une profession mais qui va
devenir et qui d'ailleurs de fait
devient chez nos jeunes une profession
et un avenir professionnel de plus en
plus désirable vous avez raison quand
vous dites que les influenceurs et les
créateurs de contenu de par la relation
de confiance qu'ils installent et qui
est installé avec avec leur audience
bénéficie d'une d'un impact très
important sur certaines décisions en
termes de choix de vie parfois en termes
de décision de choix d'achat ou
d'investissement et c'est pour cela
qu'il faut il faut regarder cette cette
activité promotionnelle avec un regard
particulier et parfois envisager des
réponses différentes à celles qui
peuvent s'appliquer à la publicité
réelle et c'est ce dont nous allons
débattre notamment dans le cadre
d'article 1 de mon collègue Arthur de la
porte merci
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
à Dominique petit pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
moi aussi félicité Arthur Delaporte et
Stéphane Vegeta pour le travail
transpartisan et la qualité du travail
engagé tant de dialogue avec Bercy qui
avait que toutes les parties prenantes
c'est un travail qui me semble
exemplaire de ce que devrait être le
travail parlementaire merci à vous parce
que vous pointez un combat avec un
combat civilisationnel qui est un combat
de société à minima celui de la
régulation de la servitude marchande via
la publicité un collectif d'ONG à
pointer que c'était près de 31 milliards
de consentement des Français chaque
année à la publicité sous toutes ses
formes et je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ont
intégré le coût des influenceurs dans
leur étude il faut mettre en parallèle
de ces 31 milliards auxquels nous
consentons servilement les 3,7 milliards
maximum consacrés par la puissance
publique la prévention des questions de
santé publique sur lequel je reviendrai
en matière d'amendement les termes qui
sont employés dans votre étude relève de
du vocabulaire qui était celui pour
dénoncer les dérives sectaires
idolâtrie en prise influence nous sommes
effectivement dans un mouvement de
libération des consciences par rapport à
des à des et qui était aujourd'hui un
angle mort je me réjouis que cette non
seulement nous réjouissons que cette PPL
arrive mais nous avons déjà au groupe
socialiste au groupe écologiste que
l'initiative de Delphine bateau sur la
publicité numérique et lumineuse aura
également notre soutien parce qu'elle
participe également du même mouvement de
régulation des abus de la publicité mais
question chers collègues vont dans deux
directions la première vous avez pointé
et c'est heureux la responsabilité des
intermédiaires et notamment des
plateformes numériques je m'interroge
notamment en référence aux travaux que
nous avons faits sur la sous-traitance
et sur le devoir de vigilance sur la
responsabilité des donneurs d'ordre
est-ce que vous avez une impasse
juridique est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une étape ultérieure la question
de qui est le donneur d'ordre qui est
finalement le bénéficiaire en matière de
bénéfice économique doit-il être
juridiquement inquiété et par quelle
voie la deuxième question est une
question d'ouverture vous avez exploré
à une partie du continent du net
aujourd'hui alors que les médias
traditionnels pressent et télévision
sont relativement réguler même jamais
c'est toujours inachevé cette régulation
nous sommes sur le net sur une sorte de
jungle et de Far West est-ce que
l'expérience qui est la vôtre à travers
l'exploration du travail des
influenceurs vous invite à poursuivre le
travail pour une nouvelle civilisation
du Net pour que au milieu du village
global il y est un espace public celui
de la République
bien monsieur le rapporteur allez-y
monsieur de la porte merci chers
collègues vous appelez à mettre la
République dans ce village du numérique
et c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
par ce texte donc je vous remercie pour
pour vos propos et nous évidemment
travaillerons avec l'ensemble des
collègues qui souhaiteront s'engager
pour plus de régulation de de ce milieu
et je vais laisser mon collègue Vegeta
répondre sur la responsabilité des
plateformes et des donneurs d'ordre
alors effectivement les plateformes
jouent un rôle fondamental sont à une
partie prenante fondamentale dans le
secteur de l'influence et de l'influence
commerciale en particulier et à travers
ce texte nous souhaitons les
responsabiliser car une fine et nous
savons très bien que les influenceurs
même s'il répondront adéquatement à la
menace de sanctions notamment
financières ou même peine de prison
l'arme atomique l'art ultime c'est
finalement la modération éventuelle de
leur contenu voir la fermeture de leur
compte et c'est pour ça que les
plateformes seront alignées de par la
mention que nous faisons au sein du
texte de l'accord du DSA pour lequel
nous pouvons remercier Bruxelles d'avoir
fait un pas en avant quant à la à la
régulation de ce secteur c'est bien
cette cette reprise des termes du dessin
dans notre texte qui permettra de
responsabiliser les plateformes et de
leur donner la légitimité d'intervenir
en cas de contenu manifestement illicite
bien merci beaucoup j'ai donc monsieur
Albertini pour le groupe horizon oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
corps-à-porteurs mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre les arnaques et les dérives des
influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux
présentés par nos deux collègues
Stéphane vogeta et Arthur de Laporte
prévoient la création de la statut
d'influenceurs dans le vide juridique
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui mais
également une régulation renforcée dans
cette activité professionnelle le texte
prévoit d'interdire aux influences sur
la réalisation de certaines promotions
en particulier dès lors que les risques
existent pour la santé ou lorsqu'il
s'agit de placement d'investissement
risqué notamment dans le domaine de la
crypto-monnaie face aux nombreux cas de
dissimulation du caractère commercial
des publications faites par certains
influenceurs la loi prévoit également
une obligation d'information du public y
compris sur la pratique de vente
pratiquée afin d'éviter le cas de
surfacturation du consommateur pour un
produit en tout point identique à ceux
que l'on trouve beaucoup moins cher sur
le marché l'actualité fait effectivement
état de plusieurs cas choquants ou
telles influenceurs trompent leur
communauté d'abonnés au profit de que
peut scrupuleuses faux traitement faux
traitement médicamenteux produit
existants sur le marché revendu plus
cher promotion d'achat risqué ou de jeux
d'argent ou de hasard et à des
communautés d'abonnés comprenant de
nombreuses personnes mineures les
exemples sont nombreux et insuffisamment
traités par les services de la
répression des fraudes ce qui est
intéressant dans le projet de loi que
nous rencontrons c'est que et que nous
allons examiner ce matin c'est le groupe
horizon apparentés s'y associera c'est
l'équilibre et la mesure que vous allez
trouver messieurs les corps-à-porteurs
sur à la fois la nécessité de protéger
souvent un public qui est peu éclairé de
dissocier le bon grain de livrer comme
ça a été rappelé il y a quelques
instants la capacité que vous avez
vis-à-vis des plateformes en fonction de
leurs degré de publicité ce qui est
important c'est effectivement d'éviter
le caractère de l'osif et laisser aux
acheteurs potentiels la capacité aux
clients potentiels la capacité de se
prononcer avec une certaine confiance le
groupe Horizon est apparenté partage la
volonté de mieux encadrer ce domaine
d'activité et de mieux faire appliquer
les règles commerciales en vigueur ce
sentiment est largement partagé en
témoignage d'option qui avait été la
nôtre lors d'une proposition de loi
portée par le député Arthur de la porte
à l'unanimité en commission des affaires
économiques dans la continuité des
échanges d'alors il avait été convenu
que ce texte soit davantage travaillé
dans un esprit transpartisan c'est le
cas ce matin c'est dans ce cadre que ce
texte que aujourd'hui nous le nous le
traitons nous nous allons l'examiner le
groupe horizon apparenté soutien
naturellement cette démarche et votre en
faveur de la présente loi et la
proposition de loi je vous remercie
bien merci beaucoup monsieur Albertini
j'ai la réponse des rapporteurs monsieur
Delaporte
très succinctement merci pour vos propos
chers collègues vous évoquez notamment
le sujet du dropshipping qui fait
l'objet de nos préoccupations et qui
avait notamment été inscrit dans le la
proposition de loi que j'avais porté
initialement et que nous cherchons
aujourd'hui voilà traiter à part entière
c'est un fléau c'est un fléau qui a
conduit à ce que des consommateurs
fassent des commandes sur Internet qui
ne reçoivent parfois aucun produit qu'il
reçoive parfois des produits défectueux
ou non conformes au réglementations
européennes voire contre fait et donc
porter notre attention sur ce sujet
demander transparence et responsabilités
aux influenceurs c'est la moindre des
choses que nous pouvions faire et donc
je vous remercie pour votre soutien
merci beaucoup pas d'autres points c'est
très marrant très bien c'est noté
monsieur Chassaigne monsieur le
Président Chassaigne pour le groupe GDR
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur d'abord pour souligner
l'intérêt de cette méthode de travail
transpartisan c'est vrai que malgré les
divergences politiques on peut par cette
méthode là être beaucoup plus utile si
on peut avoir des convergences sur des
textes j'insiste beaucoup sur ce point
j'ai une phrase que j'ai que j'ai
retrouvé dans l'exposé des motifs qui à
mon avis résume bien les choses la
relation faussement intimiste développé
par ses influenceurs rassurent ceux qui
les suivent grâce au ressenti parfois
trompeur de transparence d'honnêteté de
proximité bienveillance à leur égard et
les places ainsi dans la situation de
voir leur décision d'achat déterminée
par les indications des influenceurs je
trouve que cette phrase dit tout et je
me suis référé à une enquête qui a été
faite par la DGCCRF qui a enquêtait
depuis 2021 est rendu ses conclusions en
janvier 2023 cette enquête portée sur 60
influenceurs qui ont été ciblés car très
actifs avec le résultat est loquant 60%
d'entre eux ne respectent pas la
réglementation sur la publicité des
droits de consommateur et l'enquête
révèle par ailleurs non-respect des
règles quant à la transparence du
caractère commercial des publications
notamment l'absence de mentions
obligatoires précisant que la
publication responsorisée c'est enquête
pointe enfin des pratiques illégales de
promotion de produits ou de services
risqués des opérations de promotion non
autorisées pour le compte personnel de
formation et le détournement des fonds
ou encore la promotion d'intervention
esthétique par de non professionnels de
santé et la déchet ccl’estime que les
influenceurs doivent être considérés
comme des publicitaires comme les autres
et devraient respecter les mêmes règles
elle affiche sa volonté de multiplier
les contrôles etc ça m'arrive ça m'amène
à trois constats d'abord d'abord dire
qu'on soutient que le groupe de la
Gauche des bocataires républicaine
soutient cette proposition de loi
transpartizane et que la définition
proposée des influenceurs et cohérentes
deuxième élément c'est une question que
je pose plutôt que de créer une sous
section au sein du Code de la
Consommation pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
considéré que les influenceurs étaient
des agents publicitaires à part entière
et leur faire porter exactement les
mêmes obligations responsabilités dans
une section existante et enfin un
constat avez-vous conscience que les
effectifs de la DGCCRF on
considérablement baissé entre 2007 et
2022 nous avons 911 équivalentes à un
moins nous sommes passés de de 3723 qui
va être en plein à 2812 est-ce ça va
vous conscience que pour mener une
politique de contrôle comme vous le
proposez il faut des effectifs dans la
fonction publique
monsieur Delaporte merci président
Chassaigne pour vos mots et d'avoir
souligné la nécessité de travailler de
façon trans partisane au Parlement c'est
là où nous pouvons faire le mieux notre
travail vous évoquez le rapport de la
DGCCRF qui dit que 60% des contenus ou
des influenceurs sur lesquels il y a une
investigation avait des contenus
problématiques précisons quand même la
taille de l'échantillon il s'agit de 36
influenceurs sur 60 parmi ceux qui ont
été ciblés par la DGCCRF il s'agit
nullement de l'ensemble de ceux qui
pratiquent une activité d'influence
commerciale et donc il y avait eu un
premier travail de filtrage et parfois
ces problématiques étaient mineures donc
voilà ça permet de relativiser ce sujet
mentionnons également que la plupart des
influenceurs exercent en France pour
répondre aussi au fantasmes de
l'influenceur vivante à Dubaï la plupart
vivent et exercent sur le sol français
vous posez une question très juste un
pourquoi créer une sous section du Code
de la Consommation nous nous sommes
également poser la question et c'est
toujours finalement un débat que nous
pourrons continuer d'avoir sur savoir
quel code on visait Code de la
Consommation quand du commerce ou
simplement une loi nous visant aucun
code pour l'instant on avait choisi de
privilégier le Code de la Consommation
parce qu'il nous semblait que la loi
visait d'abord à protéger les
consommateurs et les victimes de
l'influence et on s'adressait par
ailleurs à une activité d'influence mais
qui pouvait être épisodique par exemple
vous êtes d'abord un créateur de contenu
votre profession n'est pas celle d'un
agent publicitaire au sens strict mais
c'est l'activité d'influence qui est une
activité incidente accessoire mais
néanmoins essentiel à réguler
bien nous continuons avec une terminons
les orateurs groupes avec madame
Béatrice Descamps pour le groupe yote
c'est à vous merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
dans le monde des influenceurs tous
n'ont pas le même profil prenez la
blogueuse jolie Bourges qui apprend à
vivre avec un corps de grande brûlées ou
encore les nains qui sensibilisent sa
communauté au harcèlement en ligne et à
la santé mentale rien à voir finalement
avec le coup de Nadé marglata ni avec
Dylan 1,5 millions d'abonnés sur
Instagram qui faisait en novembre 2022
la promotion cela a été dit de gélules
qui guérissent les cellules cancéreuses
ces derniers sont des
influenceurstruants ils jouent sur des
ressorts vieux comme le monde ils
choisissent des cibles souvent jeunes et
crédules étire leur profit de leur
naïveté un cadre juridique pour
sanctionner ses abus existent les
escroqueries liées aux crypto actifs par
exemple relève de l'abus de confiance du
vol de l'escroquerie quant aux
publicités n'étant pas répertoriées
comme tel elles peuvent être
sanctionnées au titre de pratique
commerciale trompeuses et pourtant les
sanctions sont rares il s'agit avant
tout d'un manque de moyens de services
de l'état d'un manque de formation
également souvent défaillante concernant
ces nouvelles technologies et la lutte
contre ces formes d'arnaques en raison
aussi à des règles de droit inadaptés à
la spécificité de ces nouvelles
activités c'est pourquoi nous sommes
favorables à un encadrement plus strict
du statut d'influenceur et de leurs
agents
nous soutenons aussi une clarification
des placements de produits interdits ou
limités nous souhaiterions toutefois que
ces restrictions s'appliquent à la
malbouffe de plus en plus promu sur les
réseaux sociaux alors même que ces
effets sur la santé des adolescents sont
désastreux
un mot également sur la sensibilisation
contre les risques d'escroquerie en
ligne dans les établissements scolaires
c'est une bonne initiative mais
n'oublions toutefois pas que l'école ne
peut pas tout faire et combien la
famille joue un rôle fondamental dans le
rapport aux écrans et la protection de
leurs enfants nous nous interrons en
outre sur deux aspects le premier celui
des sanctions applicables aux
influenceurs qu'il ne respecteraient pas
l'obligation d'afficher un bandeau
signalant que le contenu est réservé aux
personnes majeures où leurs obligations
résultant du dropshipping la seconde est
celle de l'articulation de ces nouvelles
obligations avec le droit européen
notamment le digital service actes je
terminerai en vous remerciant moi aussi
Messieurs les rapporteurs pour votre
travail
merci beaucoup monsieur Vegeta je vous
remercie pour vos propos les sujets
abordés sont nombreux et on a l'occasion
nous aurons l'occasion d'en débattre
tous ensemble ce matin simplement pour
rebondir sur les propos de mon corps
rapporteur et vous propose sur les
moyens mis à disposition notamment de la
DGCCRF nous avons justement une audition
avec avec cette organisme régulateur
hier et nous avons pu mieux mieux
appréhender le travail auquel faut fasse
les 1800 agents notamment et inspecteurs
qui qui sont chargés de réguler et qui
ont parfois la sensation effectivement
de devoir vider l'océan avec une petite
cuillère je pense que dans le cadre des
annonces que notre texte n'est pas le
cadre
adéquat pour proposer une augmentation
du manque de enfin une augmentation des
moyens budgétaires notamment mais je
pense que Bercy dans le cadre des
annonces à venir aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur ce sujet et nous ne
pouvons effectivement concerger
collectivement les moyens mis à
disposition à être à la mesure des
enjeux merci
bien nous terminons avec Madame
lahernous pour le groupe écologiste
c'est à vous
chers collègues Dylan Terry Thierry qui
vante des produits tuant les cellules
cancérigènes Julien tanti 6 millions
d'abonnés sur Instagram qui vendent de
la poudre à charbon sans ces blanchir
les dents mais reconnu comme dangereuse
pour la santé des jeunes ruinés par les
arnaques aux crypto-monnaies de Marc
lata la liste des arnaques de ce que
nous appelons aujourd'hui les
influenceurs et longues et nous ne
connaissons certainement qu'une infime
partie de leur ampleur mon collègue
Aurélien Tachet est interpellé depuis
des mois par des jeunes dans sa
circonscription sur l'ampleur des
arnaques liées aux influenceurs un sujet
qui fait écho à son travail sur les abus
publicitaires des paris sportifs en
ligne dans les deux cas les principales
victimes sont souvent des jeunes des
quartiers populaires c'est ainsi que
comme vous le savez il a décidé de
lancer un travail d'expertise sur le
sujet déposé au mois de novembre une
proposition de loi visant à réguler
l'activité des influenceurs les pouvoirs
publics et notamment le gouvernement ont
tardé à réagir par ailleurs la DGCCRF
n'est aujourd'hui pas dotée des moyens
financiers et techniques pour agir et de
très nombreuses escroqueries restent
impuni alors que des sanctions
pourraient déjà être prises si une
véritable volonté existait tous semble
permis sur un marché aujourd'hui sans
foi ni loi augmenter les moyens de la
DGCCRF est primordial aujourd'hui les
pouvoirs publics ont également tardé à
réagir alors que depuis des mois le 13
célèbre coupe Marc Blatta Marc et Nadé
Blatta et d'autres personnalités
sévissent sur les réseaux sociaux ont
pratiquant ce qu'on appelle une arnaque
au trading le trading de crypto monnaie
attire en plus de plus en plus
d'investisseurs mais il est aussi devenu
un terrain plus que favorable aux
escroqueries on apprenait par exemple au
mois d'août de l'année dernière qu'un
youtubeur se faisant appeler cryptogouv
aurait arnaqué près de 300 personnes et
détournées 4 millions d'euros en leur
proposant des investissements dans la
crypto-monnaie et ces escroquerie
touchent de plus en plus de jeunes qui
et pas qui pour épargner leur argent
mises sur les crypto-monnaies d'après un
récent sondage Opinionway 14% des 18-25
ans déclare envisager d'investir dans
les crypto monnaie ou déjà en possédé il
faut donc agir avec cette proposition de
loi nous allons dans ce sens chers
collègues puisque vous proposez que les
influenceurs ne puissent plus promouvoir
un projet crypto posté contre une
rémunération ce que le groupe écologiste
salue afin de sécuriser encore davantage
ses activités et surtout de protéger les
consommateurs et l'appairer donc urgent
de mieux réguler l'activité des
influenceurs mais cette régulation doit
être adaptée à la réalité économique et
permettent un développement sain et
responsable de la filière mon collègue
Aurélien Tachet a estimé qu'après la
poursuite des auditions menées il
fallait trouver un équilibre entre
régulation et sanctions l'économie des
créateurs de contenu est plus large que
les seuls acteurs coupables d'arnaque de
délits ou de mauvaises pratiques de
nombreux jeunes notamment issus de
quartiers populaires ont des pratiques
saines et ne doivent pas être
sanctionnées le texte que vous présentez
ce matin quand tu as donc de nombreuses
mesures intéressantes que nous
soutiendrons néanmoins ne pourrions-nous
pas envisager l'élaboration d'un cadre
de référence avec les parties prenant du
secteur et une réflexion sur le rôle et
les obligations des plateformes de
contenu je vous remercie
alors Monsieur de la porte
merci monsieur le Président merci chers
collègues pour vos propos et pour avoir
rappelé le travail d'Aurélien taché
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
sujets et je vais essayer dans la minute
qui me reste de condenser le propos
Dian Terry parler même pas des cellules
cancéreuses mais des cellules
cancérigeuses pour reprendre voilà
l'expression de ce grand médecin
l'envoyer un peu l'absurdité des choses
et aussi ce qui a choqué nombreux
d'entre nous et qui incarnaient
finalement les dérives de l'influence de
l'écho et les arnaques aux copies
trading que nous allons essayer de
réguler je finirai par le dernier point
que vous mentionnez dans le 20 secondes
qu'il me reste sur le cadre de référence
avec les parties prenantes
vous ne savez bien entendu que Bercy a
lancé les consultations avec les
plateformes notamment et que le ministre
va procéder à certaines
informations et comment dire annonces
dans les prochains jours et nous serons
heureux de pouvoir discuter la semaine
prochaine en séance de la manière dont
nous pouvons intégrer la potentielle
charte à destination des plateformes
notamment pour mieux encadrer le secteur
de façon merci beaucoup je vous propose
de passer aux questions individuelles je
me suis signé ri il y avait une question
d'en comprendre toutes les questions
individuelles une maximum et vous
concluez un rapporteur monsieur signeri
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président cette
proposition de loi vise à protéger nos
concitoyens des influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux et médias en ligne comme
YouTube si la plupart du temps il s'agit
de vidéos anodines avec du maquillage
des vêtements et de la décoration et du
sport malheureusement cela va parfois
plus loin avec de la publicité déguisée
pour des médicaments des opérations
chirurgicales ou déplacement financier
douteux afin d'éviter l'abus de
confiance de la part des influenceurs
auprès de leur communauté qui sont
souvent composées de jeunes facilement
influençable cette proposition de loi
propose de responsabilité
responsabilisée et sanctionner tous les
influenceurs leurs agences les
annonceurs ainsi que les plateformes de
diffusion comme mes collègues avant moi
je suis bien évidemment favorable à ce
texte car il est urgent que les
influenceurs prennent leur
responsabilité pour les contenus qu'il
produisent et diffusent et pour
lesquelles ils sont rémunérés protéger
nos concitoyens doit toujours être notre
priorité j'espère que nous aurons
uneanimité sur ce texte et je félicite
ces deux rapporteurs merci monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup monsieur Vigier
merci monsieur le Président et merci aux
deux rapporteurs pour la qualité de leur
travail vous l'avez dit mais depuis une
dizaine d'années le marché des
influenceurs connaît une croissance
exponentielle et l'image du secteur a
été ternie par des pratiques
frauduleuses qui peuvent mettre en
danger la santé des consommateurs en
effet vous le savez la promotion de
produits contrefaits ou ne respectant
pas les normes c'est généralisé mais la
loi ne semble pas impuissante face à ses
dérives et vous le savez ainsi depuis
2020 l'état mobilise de nombreux
services pour lutter contre ces
pratiques notamment la répression des
fraudes et des douanes alors oui pour
créer un statut d'influenceur mais en
parallèle ne faut-il pas aussi mieux
former ou donner plus de moyens aux
autorités au service de l'État face à
ces nouvelles formes d'arnaque je vous
remercie merci beaucoup on continue avec
Monsieur Roland
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
également à mon tour félicité nos deux
rapporteurs hier soir nous avons eu une
audition au cours de laquelle les
personnes qui nous répondaient ont
clairement aussi mis en avant la lenteur
qu'il y avait à avoir des réponses
judiciaires ou administratives au fait
qu'ils avaient pu relever qu'est-ce que
vous proposez justement pour qu'il y ait
une accélération des procédures et puis
n'est-il pas opportun aussi de prévenir
avant de guérir et d'avoir des campagnes
notamment dans les établissements
scolaires pour prévenir les jeunes
publics des dangers que peuvent induire
certains influenceurs je vous remercie
bien y a-t-il d'autres demandes de
questions individuelles avant qu'on
commence l'examen des amendements
une fois deux fois trois fois adjugé
très bien on va commencer donc
les amendements à moins que vous ayez
une réponse à formuler allez-y oui pour
répondre vous avez posé chers collègues
sur des questions sur deux points je
vais répondre sur la question des moyens
ce qui permettra aussi de répondre au
président Chassaigne par rapport à ce
qui évoquait tout à l'heure sur la
DGCCRF aujourd'hui il y a 1800 agents à
la DGCCRF qui sont responsables chargés
de faire des enquêtes nous avons été
avec Stéphane vogeta visiter la DGCCRF
lundi dernier et nous avons constaté que
ces agents avaient de multiples tâches
il n'était pas spécialisé en tout cas
sur la gestion de l'influence et il
pouvait s'occuper de différentes choses
donc peut-être qu'il conviendrait de
revoir certaines procédures de
spécialiser certains agents mais aussi
sur la manière dont on procède à ses
investigations et ce qui peut donner
l'impression que l'État ne fait rien
c'est qu'il y a des campagnes annuelles
de la DGCCRF et donc là on en a une qui
a visé 60 influenceurs mais finalement
quand il y a des signalements qui sont
faits par les internautes sur signal
conso ces signalement ne donnent pas
forcément lieu à une action
administrative ils informent la DGCCRF
et lui permettre derrière de cibler ces
contrôles l'année suivante mais voyez
qu'il y a en fait finalement un décalage
temporel et même un décalage tout court
entre le signalement et l'action et ça
ça nécessite sans doute de revoir
certaines procédures et des moyens
supplémentaires évidemment il en faudra
toujours
en ce qui concernement la formation que
vous avez évoquée bien évidemment les
établissements scolaires c'est important
on commence par former la jeunesse et
c'est bien sûr le cadre de dans le cadre
de l'article 5 que nous proposerons que
les élèves de CM2 et de 5e soit
sensibilisés aux enjeux de l'influence
commerciale et qu'on leur mette en main
les outils qui leur permettront de mieux
discerner les risques potentiels mais
former les influenceurs et les créateurs
de contenu c'est également important et
là c'est au secteur de s'organiser de
s'autoréguler de ne mettre à disposition
de ces acteurs tous les outils
juridiques mais aussi de formation de
monter en compétences nécessaires nous
saluons notamment l'initiative de la
création de certificat de l'influence
responsable de par la RPP qui permettra
notamment de sensibiliser une partie du
secteur mais d'autres acteurs comme
l'unique par exemple qui regroupe de
nombreux agents d'influenceurs et qui
représentent de nombreuses influenceurs
de là aussi permettre que se mettre en
place des formations et des outils qui
ainsi aideront les acteurs du secteur à
être plus familier avec la loi et à la
respecter
bien tout le monde a pu s'exprimer je
vous propose de commencer
allez on y va article additionnel avant
l'article premier j'ai un amendement
proposé par Monsieur Delaporte et
Monsieur Vegeta qu'ils présentent
monsieur de la porte merci monsieur le
Président il s'agit d'un amendement
rédactionnel visant à clarifier la
structure de la prison de proposition de
loi en insérant des titres et des titres
de chapitres
bien y a-t-il des expressions dans la
salle non et bien écoutez je vais donc
le mettre voir l'amendement du
rapporteur qui est pour alors attendez
je précise avant de mettre voix parce
que il y a une Armande switch qui sont
passés ces dernières 24 heures donc on
m'indique que les députés suivants ne
peuvent pas voter puisqu'ils ne sont pas
membres au formalement de la commission
mais je suis masségliga Madame
abomangolie madame Amiot madame Descamps
madame Betty bolognaise madame monsieur
esquennégoce et Monsieur Blanchet et
Monsieur Saint-Huile ne sont pas membres
de la commission donc je vous demanderai
de ne pas lever la main histoire que je
puisse compter convenablement et éviter
d'avoir quelques surprises je sais que
c'est un réflexe que je préfère le
préciser avant donc vous pouvez bien
évidemment parler vous pouvez aucun
problème vous exprimez commission
beaucoup de liberté dans cette
commission mais vous pouvez pas lever la
main quand on passe au vote donc je le
mets aux voix qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté article
additionnel avant l'article de j'ai
l'amendement 52 toujours la même chose
monsieur le rapporteur messieurs les
rapporteur qui le défend de la porte
merci il s'agit d'une réécriture de
l'article premier qui est issu de la
concertation que nous avons menée avec
les collègues les administrations les
agences qui procèdent donc à une
réécriture de la définition droite de
l'activité d'influence commerciale par
voie électronique
il s'agit donc de maintenir les éléments
cardinaux qui étaient prévus dans le
texte initial à savoir l'inclusion de
cette dans cette définition des
personnes physiques ou morales la
communication au public d'un contenu par
voie électronique et l'existence d'une
contrepartie économique ou de toute
nature parce que aujourd'hui l'un des
problèmes c'est que des avantages en
nature ne sont pas considérés comme une
forme de rémunération donc en échange de
l'activité de promotion les ajouts
proposés concernent la qualification des
contenus promus portant sur les biens
les services ou sur une cause quelconque
précision également que cette nouvelle
rédaction exclue la notion de notoriété
dont certains collègues nous ont parlé
qui est trop difficile notamment à
qualifier pour le juge en tout cas c'est
ce qui nous semble et qui impliquerait
de rentrer dans une de seuil par
ailleurs qui n'est pas efficiente
puisque nous avons vu aussi que ce qu'on
appelait les micros influenceurs
pouvaient avoir avec leur audience
réduit néanmoins un impact fort sur les
comportements de consommation des
consommateurs bien y a-t-il je vais
passer au sous amendement excusez-moi le
166 monsieur Albertini oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur Madame les monsieur
rapporteurs mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues effectivement c'est un sous
amendement qui tente à clarifier la
notion de qui communique la volonté
c'est de faire en sorte de dissocier la
notion d'activité commerciale pure et de
celle de celui d'influenceurs la
proposition est donc d'indiquer
qu'immobilise sa notoriété pour
communiquer ce qui permettrait de viser
ainsi de préciser l'activité
d'influenceurs de l'activité purement
commerciale bien j'ai un autre sous un
manquement qui est présenté madame
spielboot allez-y le 196
merci monsieur le Président je propose
un amendement qui permet de ne pas
entraver l'activité d'entreprise qui
envoie des échantillons de produits ou
qui proposent des dons en nature de
faible valeur sans contrepartie sans
leur demander d'avoir des éléments de
promotion de leurs produits c'est une
sorte de dons de produits qui est fait
comme c'est fait aujourd'hui dans la
presse traditionnelle dans les magazines
féminins par exemple une marque de
parfumerie va envoyer ses produits
cosmétiques à elle le Figaro Madame etc
pour que les journalistes puisent tester
et s'ils le souhaitent parler du produit
donc c'est un bon exemple je
souhaiterais donc vous proposer un sous
amendement qui prévoit d'exclure
certains avantages en nature lorsque
leur valeur est inférieure à un montant
qui serait défini par décret ça
permettrait aussi à de nombreuses
entreprises en création innovation
française responsable socialement
écologiquement qui n'ont pas de moyens
publicitaires de pouvoir pouvoir faire
ses dons à des influenceurs plus ou
moins connus bien merci beaucoup j'ai le
150 de Madame Morel
que ne relèvent pas de l'activité
d'influence commerciale par voie
électronique les personnes physiques ou
morales qui assurent uniquement la
promotion devient au service qu'ils
produisent directement sur la vise à
introduire la proposition que vous
faisiez au départ qui consistait en
permettre entre autres à un producteur
de promouvoir ses produits sur les
réseaux sociaux sans être inquiété par
cette loi je vous remercie merci enfin
j'ai un sous un moment de Madame en
grand le son monsieur le Président vous
n'êtes pas hier sans savoir que les
influenceurs toujours en quête de
diversification de leurs sources de
revenus sont de plus en plus nombreux à
lancer leur commerce Caroline Receveur
et Jeanne Damas pour ne citer qu'elle
possède à L2 6 millions 5 abonnés sur
Instagram toutes les deux possèdent une
entreprise dont elle n'hésite pas à
faire la promotion auprès de leur très
nombreux abonnés c'est pourquoi par ces
amendements nous proposons d'étendre le
cadre valable pour les promotions
réalisées pour autrui à celles réalisées
par les influenceurs pour leur propre
compte
merci donc là c'était les sous
amendements à votre amendement messieurs
les rapporteurs j'ai maintenant une
discussion commune donc on va continuer
la présentation des amendements dans la
discussion commune monsieur tâcher avait
présenté le 117 qu'il défend madame
l'aire nous ça dit cet amendement visa
définir la pratique du marketing
d'influence plutôt qu'un statut ou une
profession l'activité d'influenceurs ou
de créateurs de contenu et tant bien
plus large que la simple promotion
publicitaire il serait plus juste
opérationnel et robuste juridiquement de
définir la pratique de l'influence
commerciale afin de viser véritablement
les pratiques commerciales et les
dérives en cause cette définition
permettra d'appréhender l'ensemble des
pratiques commerciales des différentes
personnes faisant du marketing
d'influence que cela soit leur activité
principale ou secondaire comme cela peut
être le cas pour les artistes
personnalités médiatiques mais également
des métiers plus traditionnels comme
boulanger au médecin la définition de la
pratique du marketing d'influence sur un
ajout pertinent et nécessaire au sein du
Code de la Consommation pour renforcer
la régulation et la protection du
consommateur
je vous remercie j'ai dans la discussion
commune un amendement 63 de Madame Duby
Muller c'est à vous
merci en effet donc cet article 1 est
important puisque il s'agit donc de la
définition de l'activité
de l'influence commerciale que vous
proposez et qui va dans le bon sens par
cet amendement donc je souhaite que nous
allions plutôt vers le statut ou enfin
par votre définition va vers le statut
ou la profession
l'activité d'influenceurs ou de
créateurs de contenu étant bien plus
large que la simple promotion
publicitaire il apparaît plus
opérationnel de définir la pratique de
l'influence commerciale afin de viser
véritablement les pratiques commerciales
et les dérives en cause et cette
définition permettrait d'appréhender
l'ensemble des pratiques commerciales
des différentes personnes faisant du
marketing d'influence que ce soit pour
leur activité principale ou secondaire
et donc cette définition telle que je la
propose serait un ajout pertinent et
nécessaire au sein du Code de la
Consommation pour renforcer la
régulation et la protection du
consommateur
je vous remercie madame messieurs les
rapporteurs quel est votre avis sur les
différents sous amendements qui portent
sur le 44 que vous venez de présenter et
sur les deux amendements en discussion
commune
merci monsieur le Président je vais
commencer par l'amendement de Monsieur
Albertini qui finalement vise à
réintroduire la question de la notoriété
pour communiquer à ce stade ça sera
plutôt une demande de retrait j'aimerais
qu'on puisse rediscuter de ce point en
vue de la séance parce que comme je l'ai
évoqué la question de la notoriété n'est
pas forcément la meilleure manière de
caractériser l'influenceur en raison des
seuils puisque voilà est-ce que à 100
abonnés 500 abonnés 1000 abonnés on a
une notoriété ou est-ce que c'est à
partir de plusieurs millions et voilà
peut-être que c'est la question de la
personnalité bref je vous invite à
retravailler rediscuter de ça en séance
et approfondir les échanges avec les
différents administrations donc
défavorables s'il n'y a pas de retrait
sur l'amendement suivant 186 de Madame
Spiel
vous évoquez
vous évoquez de fixer la valeur des
avantages en nature dans un décret
nous avons considéré que dans la
définition il y avait la question de la
contrepartie et donc que la publicité
était faite en contrepartie d'un don
lorsque vous recevez un échantillon
gratuit envoyé de manière large et qu'il
s'agit pas d'un partenaire spécifique à
priori vous ne rentrez pas dans le champ
de la loi en revanche nous sommes
défavorables à l'idée de mettre des
seuils parce que si vous faites si vous
recevez par exemple un produit de faible
valeur mais d'une extrême dangerosité
nous risquons finalement de les exclure
du champ alors qu'il mériterait d'être
acquis si vous dites par exemple 10
euros 5 euros alors que voilà une
bouteille d'alcool vaut 4 euros
j’évoque l'alcool mais ça pourrait être
bien d'autre chose
alors sur le point suivant
vous suggérez chers collègues Morel de
réintroduire un point que nous avions
évoqué dans nos échanges préparatoires
nous l'avons retiré suite aux échanges
avec les administrations et services
juridiques des ministères notamment pour
éviter les effets de bord
voilà ça ferait courir un risque
juridique notamment ça permettrait
d'échapper au régime juridique mis en
place en prétexte qu'ils font seulement
la proposition de leur propre produit
donc voilà c'est plutôt une demande de
retrait ou avis défavorable sur ce point
sur l'amendement de Madame Engrand cette
demande est déjà satisfaite par la
rédaction actuelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons opté pour la notion
de bénéfice économique plus large et qui
intègre donc votre sujet de
préoccupation demande de retrait car
satisfait il y a vite défavorable pour
les deux derniers amendements de
réécriture complète de l'article c'est
deux amendements madame du mineur Madame
La Mouette pour Monsieur tâcher
finalement
qu'on conduise à ce que les travaux que
nous avons menés de façon collégiale
soit tout simplement écrasée il s'agit
d'un amendement qui a été proposé par
Lumix donc l'Union des métiers de
l'influence qui avec qui nous avons eu
l'occasion d'échanger mais il est
beaucoup plus large que le champ de la
réécriture de cet article donc ça sera
un avis défavorable ou plutôt une
demande de retrait si vous voulez que
les amendements que nous écrivons en ce
moment puissent voilà faire l'objet si
vous voulez vous pourrez repréciser la
réécriture en séance à partir de ces
amendements de l'unique mais ça nous
semble bien trop vaste et contraire à
l'esprit de ce que nous sommes en train
de faire
bien donc c'est défavorable à la
totalité des sous amendements et des
amendements d'accord très bien j'ai
plusieurs demandes de parole je me suis
Éric Bothorel qui souhaitait s'exprimer
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
souligne le caractère transpartisan de
du travail que vous nous proposez ce
matin et sa qualité pour autant je vois
très contre les définitions qui sont
proposées ici je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi mes chers collègues
même sous amendé la semaine dernière je
me suis rendu auprès d'une entreprise
qui s'appelle xtrel qui fait des très
beaux simulateurs de vol il se trouve
qu'ils ont gagné il se trouve que par
ailleurs ils ont gagné un appel d'offre
pour faire le simulateur de vol de la
wax j'en ai fait un tweet j'ai été reçu
là-bas j'ai pris un déjeuner en
contrepartie en nature si j'applique
strictement ce que vous avez écrit
probablement que je suis obligé de
mettre un bandeau je me rends dans un
pays dans le cadre de mon mandat de
président d'un groupe d'amitié le voyage
va être payé en partie par le pays qui
m'accueille ce pays a une situation
particulière sur les giclés géopolitique
je vais probablement défendre sa cause
et donc si je prends la définition que
vous proposez
probablement que si je communique sur ce
déplacement alors je rentrerai dans le
champ de l'influence c'est ainsi que je
lis la définition que vous nous proposez
ce matin et c'est pour ça que je voterai
contre
est-ce que vous pouvez toujours faire de
la promotion de la Bretagne chers
collègues ça c'est ça la question est-ce
que j'ai quelqu'un pour porter la
contradiction à Monsieur Bothorel
allez-y chers collègues
oui tout simplement les exemples que
vous nous citer chers collègues ne
relèvent pas de la pratique commerciale
et je pense que justement la définition
qui est proposée ici par qui est proposé
ici par nos deux rapporteurs
quand on aime bien l'activité de
l'influence commerciale à de l'influence
commerciale et je crois même que un peu
plus loin nous avons justement des
amendements qui permettent
éventuellement si ça peut vous rassurer
de d'exclure les activités de
représentants élus
alors comme l'adoption éventuelle de
cette amendement ferait tomber la
totalité des amendements sur l'article
premier je vais élargir la discussion si
vous souhaitez vous exprimer parce que
je pense que c'est important que je
puisse que chacun puisse exprimer et ce
qu'il y a d'autres demandes de prise de
parole avant que je mette aux voix
il n'y a pas de demande de additionnel
donc je vais donner la parole aux
rapporteur pour répondre et je mettrai
vos voix chers collègues je voudrais
vous rassurer publiquement vous n'êtes
pas concerné par ce chemin on vise
l'influence commerciale vous ne retirez
pas de bénéfices économique de la
promotion quand vous vous rendez dans
une entreprise et que vous êtes invité à
déjeuner des d'ailleurs je précise que
si la valeur du déjeuner est supérieure
à une certaine somme vous êtes dans
l'obligation de la déclarer mais ça
s'inscrit dans les règles déontologiques
qui sont relatives à l'exercice du
mandat de député si vous souhaitez
éviter les effets de bord sur les
parlementaires nous pourrons réfléchir à
sous amendement en séance mais il me
semble là que l'on vise une activité une
pratique commerciale à but commercial et
voilà vous vous êtes exclus du champ
mais si vous voulez on pourra en
rediscuter plus tard
j'entends l'argument mais je prends
précisément on écrit le droit et vous et
vous prenez du soin à l'écrire je prends
précisément la définition telle que vous
nous la proposez toute personne physique
au moral qui communique par public vous
définissez l'action et c'est ensuite que
vous caractérisez le fait que ce soit
une activité commerciale ça n'est pas le
préambule on ne dit pas vous en tant que
parlementaire vous êtes protégé du fait
que vous ne mettez pas enfin vous
n'exerce pas une mission d'activité
commerciale ce que vous nous proposez de
voter c'est une caractérisation d'un
certain nombre d'actions dont je
revendique que nous les menons de la
même manière qu'à cet homme
d'influenceurs et c'est seulement
ensuite dans la deuxième partie de la
rédaction de votre article premier que
vous en faites une conclusion que c'est
une activité commerciale point
bien on est suffisamment éclairé je vous
propose donc de passer au mode je vais
d'abord mettre au voile les différents
sous amendements donc le Albertini 166
ayant reçu un avis défavorable des
rapporteurs n'est pas retiré il est
maintenu qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté le spielboot 1896 avec un
avis de retrait ou des favorable il est
maintenu madame spielboutte qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté le 150 de
Madame Morel avec un avis de retrait au
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le en grand 139 avec
un avis défavorable des rapports qui est
pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté je
vais donc mettre voir l'amendement 44
ainsi sous amender avec les deux sous
amendements qui ont été adoptés qui est
pour la maman
qui est contre
il est adopté fait donc tomber les deux
amendements qui suivaient qui étaient en
discussion commune et il fait tomber la
totalité du reste des amendements qui
portaient sur l'article premier qui est
ainsi rédigé
nous passons à l'article additionnel
après l'article premier le 114
rappuyez sur le bouton
merci monsieur le Président c'est pour
but de préciser la possibilité de
majorer le montant de la demande
encourue par l'influenceur pour le non
respect des interdictions de promotion
mentionner cet article cette majoration
pour alors atteindre 100% du montant de
la du prix de la promotion afin
d'apporter un caractère véritablement
dissuadif à l'interdiction
je vous remercie quelle est la vie des
rapports
sur le sujet
sur le rapporteur votre avis oui moi je
traîne demande de retrait pour
l'amendement 114 avec une préférence
pour le 107 de Monsieur Studer qui nous
paraît mieux formulé avec un avis
favorable la protection des mineurs est
un sujet essentiel et je vous remercie
chers collègues madame Morel monsieur
Suder et l'ensemble des parlementaires
sur ce sujet pour vos travaux qui nous
permettront voilà de mieux protéger les
mineurs sujets essentiels et non
définira en droit l'activité d'influence
commerciale qui offre par ailleurs de
nouvelles perspectives mais dont on doit
protéger les mineurs sur les plateformes
concernées c'est ce que vous proposez
c'est ce que nous soutenons monsieur
escenego c'est ce que vous le maintenez
ou est-ce que vous le retirez retirez
vous le retirez c'est noté nous avons
maintenant une discussion commune qui
est prévue sur le 107 monsieur stude
monsieur sigen sule madame Morel allez-y
merci monsieur le président
d'en discuter à l'instant un amendement
qui est proposé par notre collègue Bruno
Studer qui a beaucoup travaillé sur ce
sujet et qui vient actualiser la loi
enfant influenceurs afin de garantir une
protection maximale des mineurs
concernant l'utilisation de leur image
en ligne et tirer les conséquences de la
définition en droit de l'activité
d'influence commerciale par voie
électronique en effet la portée des
obligations pesant sur l'exploitation de
l'image des mineurs en ligne et
renforcée via son élargissement à
l'ensemble des plateformes en ligne
auparavant seuls les plateformes de
partage de vidéo était concernés et cet
amendement il propose également de
préciser que le contrat qu'il lit
l'annonceur la personne exerçant une
activité d'influence commerciale par
voie électronique et sont représentant
légal lorsque celle-ci est mineure est
soumis aux définitions qui étaient au
disposition qui était déjà définie à
l'article 2 de la présente proposition
de loi je vous remercie je vous remercie
madame Amiot pour le 32
oui merci monsieur le Président
par cette amendement nous souhaitons
protéger nos enfants en assurant donc
qu'un enfant de moins de 16 ans ne puis
sans autorisation individuelle préalable
accordée par l'autorité administrative
être à quelques titres que ce soit
engagés par un influenceur il s'agit en
espèce donc de reprendre le dispositif
de protection des enfants existants
s'appliquant notamment aux activités de
cinéma et du spectacle
et donc encore une fois il s'agit
d'étendre le droit existant en y
intégrant l'activité de la création de
contenu et de l'influence commerciale
dans le but de protéger nos enfants
merci beaucoup messieurs les rapporteurs
quel est votre avis sur ces deux
amendements en discussion commune si
monsieur le Président comme je
l'évoquais ça sera un avis favorable sur
le ce17 sur le ce 32 il s'agit
finalement d'un amendement qui propose
d'élargir la portée de la loi Studer
au-delà des contenus publicitaires
mobilisant un enfant à titre principal
nous sommes chers collègues et nous
avons l'occasion d'avoir des discussions
lors des groupes de travail sur le sujet
sensible mais peut-être qu'il faudrait
retravailler cela et demande de retrait
pour redéposer au stade de la séance par
rapport à l'amendement 107 qui sera
adopté je l'espère voir retravailler la
rédaction pour que voilà on puisse
intégrer ça en lien avec Monsieur
studiant notamment voilà demande de
retrait des fois avec défavorable bien
pas de demande de prise de parole je
vous propose donc de le mettre au voile
le 107 avec un avis favorable du
rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté ce qui fait
tomber également le le 32 il fait tomber
le 32 nous avons le 47 de Monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
d'un amendement très bien je le mets
donc au voie qui est pour qui contre il
est adopté amendement pouvant être
soumis un discussion commune j'ai
d'abord un amendement présenté par
Messieurs les rapporteurs le 45
c'est monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement est important puisqu'il vise
à rappeler le cadre juridique relatif à
l'encadrement de la promotion de bien et
de services ainsi que de la publicité
applicable à l'activité d'influence
commerciale par voie électronique telle
que définie par l'article premier de la
présente loi telle que nous l'avons
adopté cette ce rappel il est destiné
aux influenceurs mais aussi aux
consommateurs et c'est finalement la
vertu pédagogique de la loi que de
rappeler l'ensemble des interdictions
qui pèsent sur les influenceurs et je
mentionnerai notamment et c'est pour
cela que nous l'avons mis en particulier
le respect du cadre législatif actuel et
celui de la loi Evain qui prévoit des
dispositions spécifiques notamment
concernant la protection des mineurs
voilà donc cet article est important
parce que il montre que les influenceurs
font l'objet et sont soumis aux droits
communs
bien donc sur cet amendement j'ai un
sous amendement le 179 qui est présenté
par Madame Morel allez-y
non dans la continuité des discussions
précédentes sous amendement ils vise à
sécuriser le statut juridique à nouveau
des influenceurs de moins de 16 ans afin
que la rémunération qu'il perçoivent-ils
de leur activité fasse l'objet de la
même réglementation que celle dont on
parlait auparavant qui en cas de
l'exploitation commerciale de l'image
d'enfants de moins de 16 ans sur les
plateformes en ligne cette disposition
elle précise très clairement que les
représentants légaux peuvent disposer
d'une partie de la rémunération mais la
majeure partie des revenus doit être
versée à la Caisse des dépôts et des
consignations qui en assurent la gestion
jusqu'à la majorité de l'enfant je vous
remercie bien nous avons une discussion
commune donc monsieur Girardin pour le
26 dans cette même discussion allez-y
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement concerne effectivement
l'activité de la filière vitivinicole
donc il est pas nécessaire de rappeler
toute l'importance pour l'économie
française et notamment de sa
contribution à la balance du commerce
extérieur français en France la loi Evin
entrée en vigueur le 1er novembre 92
c'était fixé pour objectif de réduire la
consommation de tabac et d'alcool
d'informer sur les risques et de
protéger les mineurs il prévoit
notamment l'interdiction la publicité en
faveur de tabac et de l'alcool faisant
de la France à des pays les plus
réglementés en la matière et notamment
qui sont dans la publicité cette loi
modifiée en 2016 permet notamment de
distinguer informations et promotion en
parallèle un cadre réglementaire existe
d'ores et déjà pour protéger les mineurs
des boissons alcoolisées notamment
l'interdiction de la publicité sur tous
les sites jeunesse sur les sites des
clubs et des associations sportives
enfin la consultation publique organisée
entre le 8 et 31 janvier 2023 par le
ministère de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique tu as toujours pas rendu ses
conclusions il est nécessaire d'attendre
le résultat de ces travaux avant
d'entamer toute démarche législatives à
ce sujet dans ce contexte les présente
amendements permet de rappeler que les
personnes exercent une activité
d'influence de l'article premier de la
présente loi sont soumises aux
obligations de la loi Eva en matière de
communication publicitaire et non
publicitaire sur les boissons
alcoolisées cette précision Saverne
nécessaire pour éviter toute incitation
à la consommation excessive et assurer
un encadrement efficace de l'activité
des influenceurs au regard des enjeux de
santé publique je vous remercie merci
beaucoup j'ai donc sur les sous sur le
sous amendement et sur l'amendement quel
est votre avis messieurs la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président sur le sous
amendement 179 ça sera un avis favorable
qui permet de clarifier le cadre
juridique s'appliquant aux mineurs sur
le suivant l'amendement C26 chers
collègues je vous remercie d'avoir
rappelé voilà le cadre de la loi Eva
vous l'avez mentionné voilà la
protection des mineurs est essentielle
et fort heureusement finalement dans la
définition ce 45 nous avons une approche
similaire nous rappelons qu'ils sont
soumis aux articles 33-23-2 et 33 23 4
du Code de la santé publique donc voilà
si l'amendement est adopté il sera
satisfait il tombera probablement sinon
demande de retraite alors Monsieur
Gérardin vous le maintenez
vous allez le maintenir très bien donc
c'est donc je rappelle les avis donc
c'est un avis favorable sur le
sous-amendement de Madame Morel c'est un
avis de retrait sinon défavorable
puisque j'ai une demande de prise de
parole puisque quelqu'un soit intervenir
non très bien donc je vais le mettre je
vais mettre aux voix donc d'abord le
sous-amendement de Madame Morel
avec un avis favorable des rapporteurs
qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté je mets donc
aux voix l'amendement ainsi sous adopté
ainsi sous amendée excusez-moi qui est
pour
qui est contre il est adopté il fait
tomber le 26 qui était en discussion
communique que vous avez retiré de toute
façon monsieur Gérardin donc c'est bien
noté j'ai ensuite alors là j'ai
énormément de sous amendements donc ce
que je vais vous proposer pour la clarté
de nos débats parce que si on fait la
présentation de tous les sous
amendements on va y arriver c'est de
prendre les sous amendements un par un
et d'avoir la vie de rapporteur
systématiquement un par un donc et de le
voter un par un histoire de pouvoir
faire la discussion ensemble donc
d'abord monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
les rapporteurs vous présentez votre
amendement et ensuite on ira un par un
sur les sous amendements parce que sinon
on va pas s'en sortir allez-y merci
monsieur le Président cette amendement
il est important puisqu'il propose une
réécriture plus complète des
dispositions relatives à l'encadrement
de la promotion de certains biens et
services qui étaient initialement prévus
au sein de l'article premier du texte
initial de la proposition de loi que
nous avions voté je le rappelle à
l'unanimité lors de son examen en
commission donc c'est simplement pour
permettre la reprise des différentes
interdictions
sur lesquelles je vais revenir mais que
nous pourrons évidemment discuter au cas
par cas la rédaction elle concerne
quatre domaines les produits de santé
les produits et services financiers les
jeux de hasard d'argent et les jeux
vidéo mettant en oeuvre des mécanismes
identiques l'interdiction de la
publicité en ligne dans le cadre de
l'influence commerciale porterait
d'abord sur les produits et substances
pharmaceutiques réglementées
c'est-à-dire le livre premier de la
cinquième partie du code de la santé
publique à l'exception des produits
cosmétiques des dispositifs médicaux
classés 1 ou 2 il s'agit notamment des
lunettes correctives ou des aides
auditives qui sont exemptées de cette
interdiction ainsi que de toutes les
opérations chirurgicales à viser
esthétique ou non nous nous avons pu
voir hier les ravages il est également
prévu une exception pour le relais par
des personnes exerçant l'activité
d'influence commerciale des campagnes
institutionnelles de santé nous avions
pu le voir notamment lors de la phase du
covid l'importance des financeurs pour
la promotion des bonnes pratiques il est
également prévu dans la présente
rédaction une interdiction de publicité
ciblant les produits et services
financiers présentant un risque
spécifique pour le consommateur afin de
faire face aux dérives constatées sur
les réseaux sociaux et notamment par les
collectifs de victimes d'influenceurs je
rappellerai par exemple audition que
nous avons eu hier soir du collectif
avis qui a subi et qui représente les
victimes du copy trading qui ont perdu
pour certains 1500 voir jusqu'à 50 000
euros qui sont endettés et qui ont des
conséquences extrêmes sur leur vie
sur la Rédaction le champ d'interdiction
est adapté à l'état actuel du droit est
compatible avec le périmètre de
l'article L22 16-2 du Code de la
Consommation elle ne permet pas la
publicité de crypto actif sauf pour les
opérateurs bénéficiant d'un agrément de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers la
nouvelle rédaction vient également
actualiser la rédaction de
l'interdiction par les influenceurs
commerciaux de faire de la publicité
contre rémunération pour les jeux
d'argent et de hasard ainsi que pour les
jeux vidéo comprenant une fonctionnalité
essentielle assimilable à ces mêmes jeux
et je remercie par ailleurs les
représentants de l'Association française
de des jeux vidéo libres non j'oubliais
le nom actuellement mais qui nous a
accompagné pour cette régulation pour
conserver une forme de souplesse
l'édiction d'exception et je le précise
aussi à ces différentes interdictions et
renvoyer au pouvoir réglementaire qui
pourra donc renforcer les exceptions
pour éviter les effets de bord enfin
c'est amendement prévoit que la
violation de ces interdictions soit
punie de deux ans d'emprisonnement et de
30 000 euros d'amende ainsi que d'une
peine complémentaire qui nous paraît
essentielle d'interdiction de
l'exercice d'activité d'influence
commerciale qui pourra être prononcée
par le juge l'évolution proposée par
rapport au texte initial se justifie
notamment par la nécessité de mettre en
place des peines respectant le principe
de proportionnalité
merci beaucoup on va rentrer dans une
série de sous amendements smsif et je
vais les mettre en discussion un par un
et les mettre voix un par un on commence
avec Madame en grand le 134
allez-y attendez quelqu'un voilà
merci l'amendement de réécriture que
vous proposez introduit des exceptions
et vous comprendrez aisément notre gêne
vis-à-vis de ses mentions puisque le
cadre de ces exceptions est renvoyé à
l'autorité réglementaire sans aucun sans
aucune autre forme de procès donc par
précaution nous proposons donc de
préciser le cadre de ces exceptions qui
doit être strictement limitée au
campagne d'information et de prévention
merci je remercie votre avis messieurs
les rapporteur
c'est un avis défavorable très bien pas
d'intervention je le mets donc on voit
avec la vie défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre il n'est pas adopté le 197
madame Sud
ez
le présent sous amendement a pour but de
supprimer l'interdiction de promotion de
médicaments produits pharmaceutiques et
dispositifs médicaux en effet si
l'intention de l'amendement est louable
le champ définit par cet amendement nous
semble beaucoup trop large parce qu'il
reviendrait à interdire notamment par
exemple la promotion de complément
alimentaire de vitamines de préservatif
de tests de grossesse qui sont tous
vendus librement aujourd'hui par
ailleurs s'il y a des dérives qui sont
constatées on pense notamment à la
naturopathie ou aussi à la vente
pyramidale de certains produits
alimentaires avec des systèmes de vente
qui peuvent embrigader certaines
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux on
rappelle que les influenceurs sont bien
concernés au titre de la présente loi
par l'interdiction de la publicité
mensongère mentionnée aux articles 121-1
et 121,7 du Code de la Consommation donc
pour éviter que nombre d'entreprises du
secteur et notamment de petites
entreprises qui commercialisent
notamment des compléments alimentaires
par exemple recomposés en fonction du
profil de personne ne puisse plus
s'exprimer nous sous-amendons donc en
proposant de supprimer certains
interdictions merci je vous remercie
messieurs le rapporteur votre avis merci
Madame spielbout on partage évidemment
votre intention d'éviter les effets de
bord mais il y a un risque c'est que
votre amendement qui supprime la fin de
la Linéa soit contre-productif parce
qu'il ferait que par exemple les
éléments relatifs à la fois aux
campagnes de santé publique du
gouvernement que nous avons souhaité
préserver finalement de la
caractérisation d'influence commerciale
mais aussi un certain nombre d'autres
sujets par exemple les prothèses
auditives etc soit inclus dans le
périmètre de l'influence commerciale
nous souhaitons évidemment pas je pense
à la lutte contre le VIH je suis membre
du Conseil national du sida empêcher les
campagnes de santé publique ou relatives
au droit contraceptifs néanmoins et vous
avez assisté comme moi hier soir aux
auditions des représentants des victimes
et des lanceurs d'alerte qui sont
extrêmement troublantes aujourd'hui sur
les produits de santé il y a un grand
nombre de problématiques liés à la
pratique de l'influence commerciale on a
des exemples qui s'accumulent est-ce que
chers collègues vous connaissez le
microneedling capillaire
pas encore mais en tout cas c'est une
technique qui consiste à faire passer
sous la peau une aiguille souvent à
l'aide de produits cosmétiques pour
avoir une peau parfaite un mélange de
pratique illégale de la médecine de
promotion de soin de dispositifs
médicales qui fait un carton mais qui
est interdite dans les salons
esthétiques de nombreux influenceurs en
feront la promotion nous sommes
évidemment pas fermé chers collègues à
faire évoluer le texte et nous vous
proposerons de retravailler ensemble si
l'argumentaire que je viens de
développer ne vous a pas convaincu mais
je finirai en citant un message reçu de
l'ordre des médecins qui nous dit que
les pratiques et les activités
promotionnelles lorsqu'elles porte sur
les produits pharmaceutiques dispositifs
médicaux et actes de chirurgie à
l'exception de rien leur semble
totalement fondé et donc l'ordre des
médecins adhère pleinement à ce que nous
préconisons je préciserai aussi que la
rédaction de l'article pour éviter les
effets de bord a été travaillé avec les
services juridiques du ministère de la
Santé
demande de retrait s'il vous plaît à
défaut avait défavorable mais on est
prêt à retravailler avec vous en vue de
la séance alors madame monsieur est-ce
que vous maintenez
je propose de le maintenir parce qu'il
nous semble important de protéger tous
ceux qui ont des activités légales et
conformes à ce qui se passe sur le
marché en dehors des réseaux sociaux
mais de le retravailler bien entendu
pour la séance donc vous le maintenez
pas d'autres interventions je propose
sur le rapporteur c'est le droit merci
vous le maintenez mais je tiens à dire
chers collègues que nous sommes ici en
commission et que nous devons envoyer un
message à l'ensemble de ceux qui nous
regardent et cet amendement est
notamment la partie qui risque d'être
supprimé alors à la fois sur les
campagnes du gouvernement mais sur
l'ensemble pourrait envoyer un message
négatif aux influenceurs à qui nous
adressons aujourd'hui mais aussi aux
victimes aux victimes notamment des
pratiques néfastes de promotion de faux
dispositifs médicaux donc voilà je vous
enjoins chers collègues à ne pas voter
cet amende
il est donc maintenu je vais donc le
mettre au voie avec un avis défavorable
des rapporteurs qui est pour
attendez je vais compter
qui est contre
il est adopté il fait tomber les deux
suivants
donc celui le 161 tombe le 190 tombe on
passe au 156 de Monsieur masseguia
merci monsieur le Président
c'est un amendement que j'ai construit
suite à une vidéo que j'ai vu d'un
influenceur qui s'appelle le roi des
rats qui a quelques années comment
c'est son nom chacun a son pseudo donc
il y a quelques années il avait fait une
enquête sur l'utilisation par la
plateforme twitch ou du moins par des
influenceurs sur twitch
du fait de pouvoir mettre en avant le
casino en ligne permettant donc la
tirant donc des jeunes à une pratique
qui est interdite en France et donc
l'objectif de cet amendement est de dire
que tout ce qui est interdit en France
ne peut pas de façon logique d'ailleurs
être promu au travers des réseaux
sociaux pour que des personnes qui
soient fragiles puissent être tournées à
vouloir utiliser un VPN je sais que
c'est un mot compliqué pour certains un
VPN pour pouvoir jouer à l'étranger qui
plus est s'ils sont mineurs
je vous remercie quelle est la vie des
rapporteurs sur le sujet
défavorable ça sera un avis défavorable
reprise allez-y je vais essayer
j'entends qu'il est défavorable
défavorable c'est un seul mot et
j'aurais aimé au moins une phrase en
fait qui fixe exprimer les raisons du
défavorable
je comprends donc ça ne vous dérange pas
que des mineurs puissent voir sur twitch
des casinos en ligne qui se déroulent à
Malte peut-être mais il me semblait
qu'on était là pour protéger les mineurs
sur des pratiques abusives mais bon
peut-être moi je trouverai de l'objectif
de la PPL je vous remercie chers
collègues de nécessaire
je vous remercie chers collègues de
souligner la nécessité de réguler les
casinos en ligne mais cette pratique est
déjà prohibée c'est pour ça que cette
insertion nous sommes pas
utile notamment dans cet article qui ne
vise pas à rappeler les règles déjà en
vigueur mais en créer de nouvelles
c'était la raison de mon article
défavorable mais évidemment et nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir et je vous
remercie pour votre soutien il faut
absolument protéger les publics
vulnérables et notamment les mineurs
bien il est maintenu je vais donc le
mettre au vois avec un avis défavorable
du rapporteur qui est pour
qui contre
il n'est pas adopté j'ai l'amendement
173 de Madame à beaumont-goli
pleinement interdire la promotion des
placements financiers et paris sportifs
mentionné dans cet article le collectif
à vie a fait la démonstration de la
nocivité de nombreux placements
financiers dans certains influenceurs
ont fait la promotion certaines victimes
ont perdu plusieurs milliers d'euros du
fait c'est pratique pour les jeux
d'argent en général santé publique
France relève que les jeunes sont six
fois plus susceptibles de développer une
addiction et que 70% de ses joueurs sont
endettés auprès des banques certains
services ont fait du ciblage des jeunes
et des plus précaires de nos concitoyens
une véritable stratégie commerciale avec
des slogans tels que gros risque gros
gain gros respect tout pour la daronne
etc il y va de la protection de nos
concitoyens les plus jeunes d'interdire
ce genre de promotion et de permettre
aucune exception à cette interdiction je
remercie quelle est la vie des rapports
merci madame a beaucoup mangoli pour les
mêmes raisons ça sera la pression
merci Madame Mongolie pour les mêmes
raisons ça sera un avis défavorable
parce que voilà vous l'avez montré mais
il faut qu'on laisse de la souplesse
dans les interdictions et par ailleurs
on renvoie des possibilités par décret
de le définir donc je pense que on
pourra tous participer à la consultation
mais
bien vous le maintenez je le mets donc
au vois avec un avis défavorable du
rapporteur qui est pour qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté j'ai un amendement
je vous assure que là de mon côté avec
ma vision que j'ai je n'ai pas adopté
je continue avec
Madame Gauthier bolognaise sur le 133
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement de précision vise à compléter
le quatrième alinéa on assiste à une
diversification des produits immobiliers
proposés aux investisseurs et certains
comportent aujourd'hui un risque de
perte en capital les sociétés civiles de
placement immobilier sont par exemple
des produits de placement immobilier qui
ont connu un développement exponentiel
depuis les années 2010 eu égard d'un
rendement intéressant par rapport à des
produits d'épargne plus classique
cependant ces placements sont aussi à
risque de perte en capital de manière
générale cet amendement entend protéger
les consommateurs de l'ensemble des
publicités faisant la promotion de
dispositif immobilier légaux mais à but
de l'ocif comme l'omission des clauses
la sous-estimation de l'apport ou la
surestimation des rendements je vous
remercie je vous remercie quelle est la
vie des rapporteurs
merci monsieur le Président ça sera une
demande de retrait on n'est pas
défavorable sur le fond au point que
vous mentionnez mais il faut trouver le
juste équilibre entre l'encadrement et
l'interdiction et c'est ce que nous
avons essayé à chaque fois de trouver et
là le risque c'est que dans la manière
dont c'est rédigé ça soit trop large
parce que vous visez l'ensemble du
régime et pas simplement les les SCPI
qui serait voilà risqués qui est
contourner des risques importants de
perte donc voilà on peut en discuter en
vue de la séance
je vous remercie madame Gauthier vous le
maintenez
vous le retirez très bien Madame
givernais propose le
220 merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur les rapporteurs cet amendement
vise à supprimer le principe de
promotion l'interdiction du principe de
promotion des jeux d'argent et de hasard
par les influenceurs alors je vous
rejoins sur le fait qu'il faille être en
protection des joueurs et notamment des
mineurs ce que je vous propose c'est
plutôt d'avoir une application de la loi
comme elle se fait dans les dans les
dans le cadre de la publicité
commerciale et de s'assurer finalement
que non seulement il y a les bandeaux de
prévention qui s'ajoutent aux
influenceurs mais aussi d'éviter toute
mise en scène de deux mineurs sur sur
les jeux d'argent
merci beaucoup messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le rapporteur allez-y oui merci
donc cet abonnement qui supprime
l'interdiction de principe de la
promotion des jeux d'argent et de hasard
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous nous
dites mais finalement nous on a une
vision assez différente on a auditionné
et vous étiez l'ensemble des collègues
de la Commission de l'affaire économique
était conviés les représentants du
secteur des jeux mais aussi la NJ qui
régule les jeux et voilà on peut
craindre que vous ayez des craintes
juridiques mais on y reviendra tout à
l'heure pendant les grands événements
sportifs c'est ce que nous dit la engie
les promotions d'influenceurs bondissent
et le risque pour les jeunes est
considérable donc voilà on y reviendra
sur la conséquence concrète sur la santé
publique mais nous on est défavorable à
cet amendement
merci beaucoup chez Monsieur guyaki
souhaitait s'exprimer
merci monsieur le Président je regrette
que mon premier amendement n'est pas
passé j'espère que le Surra mais
finalement il y a peut-être un point sur
lequel je suis pour l'instant d'accord
avec cette PPL qui j'espère permettra
d'être beaucoup plus transpartisane
c'est la vision qu'il a au travers du
jeu vidéo et je crois qu'il faut être
vraiment très précis le jeu vidéo est
une passion le jeu vidéo est un objet
culturel le jeu vidéo ne doit pas être
sorti de son objectif pour être un
travestissement du jeu d'argent et cette
PPL là-dessus est très claire et je suis
satisfait des échanges qui a pu avoir
entre monsieur les rapports entre
messieurs les rapporteurs et le secteurs
du jeu vidéo et de la conclusion qu'il
en sort le jeu vidéo est un objet
culturel le jeu de vidéo n'est pas un
très investissement du jeu d'argent et
là-dessus je suis donc défavorable même
si vous pouvez pas voter
très bien Madame Giverny allezzy oui je
tiens à préciser qu'il y a effectivement
eu un rapport d'évaluation sur les jeux
d'argent en 2018 dont j'étais l'auteur
nous avons pu créer cette autorité
nationale des jeux qui est très
pertinente dans dans sa relation
néanmoins je tiens à souligner que
effectivement je pense que les
influenceurs n'ont pas être plus
restreint que ce que nous resterions
dans le champ public
[Musique]
monsieur le rapporteur oui merci bon je
j'aimerais que j'aurais aimé qu'on
puisse discuter 198 en même temps parce
que c'est un véritable sujet quand on a
regardé des des pubs notamment quand
nous les représentants des sociétés de
jeunes nous ont montré des pubs il y a
un bandeau et je sais pas si vous avez
regardé ce que c'est que le bandeau
informatif
mais c'est quelque chose qui fait à peu
près allez sur un téléphone portable ça
fait 5 mm je suis pas sûr que ça
permette aux jeunes d'avoir un message
préventif on a par ailleurs eu
l'occasion de discuter avec des
chercheurs en marketing qui montrent que
les messages préventifs ont une
influence assez faible par rapport à la
confiance que porte les les spectateurs
les communautés dans les influenceurs
c'est d'ailleurs cela qui a mené
l'Espagne à interdire aux influenceurs
de faire de la pub pour les jeux
d'argent c'est un véritable sujet
pendant la coupe du monde je l'évoquais
mais les influenceurs c'est une centaine
d'influenceurs qui a été mobilisé pour
promouvoir les paris sportifs notamment
sur Instagram sur YouTube sur Twitter
80% du public des influenceurs à moins
de 34 ans et 50% à moins de 25 ans
sachant que on a évoqué il y a des
problèmes sur l'âge des comptes mais que
on sait que on en a parlé il y a
quelques semaines il y a des mineurs qui
se déclarent avoir plus de 18 ans
les mises moyennes c'est 230 euros pour
des moins de 25 ans à moitié c'est des
sommes considérables la mise moyenne ces
jeux d'argent ils sont donc dangereux
surtout quand la promesse de gains est
fausse bien sûr on ne souhaite pas
bannir les autorités françaises mais on
veut vraiment protéger protéger les
consommateurs c'est l'objet de cette loi
et c'est pour cela qu'on a mis en place
cette interdiction qui s'inspire de
l'Espagne mais elle n'interdit pas de
manière générale la promotion
bien on est éclairé on va donc le mettre
voir avec la vie défavorable des
rapporteurs qui pour
qui contre il est adopté
si monsieur le rapporteur je peux vous
assurer que si vous avez pas compté ma
présidente donc je suis désolé mais là
moi j'ai tout le monde qui lève la main
ici et là donc c'est très clair
monsieur attendez enfin je veux bien
refaire le vote mais vous avez pas
remettre en cause de façon dont je
préside donc chacun se concentre et
chacun va lever les mains et vous allez
vous exprimer donc si vous voulez vous
écouter donc on y va on passe au vote il
y a navigué favorable qui est pour cet
amendement
merci donc qui est contre il est adopté
nous donc le suivant tombe
et nous passons au
de Madame abomangoli alors
pensez tellement de moment là on
souhaite interdire la promotion cette
fois-ci des abonnements et des
pronostics des pronostics sportifs la
publicité sur les paris sportifs en
ligne prioritairement comme je dirais
plus tout à l'heure les plus jeunes et
les plus précaires qui sont la cible des
opérateurs de jeux tel que Winamax the
bête the bats je sais pas comment
prononce Unibet FDJ les dépenses en
paris sportifs en ligne des 18-24 ans
connaissent une hausse de 127% au cours
de la première moitié de l'année 2021 et
de 30% sur la seule période
correspondant à l'euro à l'Euro de
football selon une étude réalisée en
2021 les 18 24 ans seraient désormais la
tranche de la population qui effectue le
plus de transactions liées aux paris
sportifs en ligne suivi des 24 35 ans
beaucoup de sites de pronostics en ligne
sont intimement liés des facto à des
services de paris sportifs en ligne
ainsi on peut citer
sporty trader qui propose par exemple
sur son site de faire des paris sur
Betclic donc en fait il y a des
redirections nous voulons donc agir à la
fois sur les paris sportifs et sur
l'incitation à s'abonner à aux
pronostics sportifs
bien la vie des rapporteurs s'il vous
plaît ça sera un avis favorable
bien donc je le mets avec
du rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
madame minier pour le 164 et merci
monsieur le Président par ce sous
amendement nous souhaitons ajouter à la
liste des interdictions de promotion par
les influenceurs les produits et
équipements cosmétiques non certifiés
par les institutions françaises et
européennes en effet il s'agit d'un
véritable sujet de santé publique les
réseaux sociaux ont ouvert la voie à la
promotion par ses influenceurs de
produits et d'équipements cosmétiques de
ce type résultat il y a de nombreuses
personnes qui témoignent à la suite de
l'achat de ces produits de problèmes de
santé en 2020 plus de 3000 personnes se
plaignaient de perte de cheveux de
migraines de brûlures après
l'utilisation de produits capillaires
qui ont pourtant envahi les stories
quotidiennes d'influenceurs au million
d'abonnés au mois de janvier dernier le
site 60 millions de consommateurs
épingle c'est cosmétiques qui contenait
des produits nocifs allergisants
irritants et des molécules interdites en
Europe je pourrais également vous parler
des patchs brûleurs de graisse promu par
les mêmes stars des réseaux sociaux ISS
plateforme de dropshipping qui irait
jusqu'à brûler la peau des exemples
parmi tant d'autres donc afin de
protéger le public de ces influenceurs
nous proposons par cet amendement
d'ancrer dans la loi cette interdiction
de promotion sur les réseaux sociaux de
ces produits non certifiés par les
institutions françaises et européennes
je vous remercie quelle est
merci de tous amendement il propose
interdire la publicité pour les produits
et typiquement cosmétiques non certifiés
par les institutions européennes cette
publicité est d'ores et déjà interdit
dans la mesure où ces produits sont
interdits à la vente s'il ne respecte
pas la législation de l'Union européenne
nous ne sommes pas favorables en outre à
une interdiction de publicité pour les
cosmétiques
y a-t-il une intervention dont c'est un
avis défavorable monsieur le rapporteur
très bien donc je vais le mettre avec un
avis défavorable rapporteur qui est pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté madame
Engrand pour le 135
merci je ne vous apprends rien sur les
réseaux sociaux on ne trouve pas que des
photos de plats végétariens de la Tour
Eiffel ou de vos dernières visites en
circonscription parmi ces photos somme
toute très classiques se glissent des
clichés plus osés frisons même avec le
tendancieux certaines photos en maillot
de bain à la plage sont parfois un
prétexte pour faire la proposition
d'activité moins avouables ou en tout
cas beaucoup plus explicite accessible
moyennant quelques euros sur des
plateformes plus intimistes telles que
ils font cet amendement propose donc
d'indiquer le développement de ce
cet amendement propose donc d'endiguer
le développement de ce phénomène en
interdisant la promotion par des
influenceurs des photos et vidéos à
caractère pornographique merci merci
ça sera défavorable il y a une loi qui a
été votée au Sénat c'est pas l'objet de
la présente
je vous remercie je vais donc le mettre
aux voix avec un avis défavorable du
rapporteur qui est pour qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
j'ai madame trouvé qui propose le 167
qu'il défend madame à mamangolie pardon
excusez-moi madame ami aussi à vous
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à interdire la promotion
des produits alimentaires trop gras trop
riches trop sucré trop salé et en gros
ce message que nous nous enchaînons un
systématiquement à chaque fois que
que qu'une publicité sur sur l'un de ces
produits apparaît nous proposons que les
influenceurs ne le fassent pas la
promotion de ces produits tout
simplement parce que aujourd'hui il est
il s'agit d'une question de santé
publique notamment vis-à-vis des plus
jeunes publics des enfants qui voient
une une forte augmentation des cas
d'obésité infantile liées à la malbouffe
et ça va faire écho à ce que disait donc
la collecte tout à l'heure si nous
pouvions effectivement interdire la
promotion de la malbouffe donc des
produits trop gras trop sucrés trop
salés
alors je vais les mettre en discussion
commune avec le 151 et le 163 parce
qu'ils sont sur le même sujet et donc
l'adoption de l'un des trois fait tomber
les autres donc je continue la
discussion à vous avant de vous demander
votre avis mais monsieur le rapporteur
et Madame Morel propose de 151 oui merci
monsieur le Président en amendement
important pour la santé publique alors
où la santé est une préoccupation
majeure des Français il vise à cet
amendement vise à interdire la promotion
par les influenceurs des produits
alimentaires trop gras trop sucrés trop
salés c'était évoqué à l'instant mais
ici on précise que le nutri-score serait
égal à la classe D ou E en effet ces
produits ne sont pas recommandés dans le
cadre d'une alimentation équilibrée et
l'obésité on le sait est un problème de
santé publique mondiale dont l'incidence
ne cesse d'augmenter à cet égard
quelques chiffres selon l'OMS le nombre
de cas d'obésité a presque triplés à
l'échelle planétaire depuis 1975 la
France est bien entendu touchée par cet
enjeu puisque selon une étude de
l'Inserm en 2023 47,3% des adultes
serait obèse ou en surpoids et ce fléau
touche également les plus jeunes les
chiffres sont en constante augmentation
pour n'en citer qu'un seul
donc pour ne citer qu'un seul sur les
chiffres sont en augmentation mais 95%
des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans vont
continuellement sur les réseaux sociaux
et il ces réseaux sociaux influencent
87% des acheteurs dans la décision
d'achat il nous semble donc être en bon
levier d'interdire sur les réseaux
sociaux les produits dont le nitriscor
est égal à la classe D ou E je vous
remercie merci beaucoup j'ai un
troisième amendement qui est présenté
par Madame Christol
merci monsieur le Président je rebondis
effectivement sur les propos de ma
collègue et un consensus scientifique
ces dernières années sur le fait que les
messages sanitaires type pour votre
santé manger au moins cinq fruits et
légumes par jour sont inefficaces
concernant cette pub sur les aliments de
mauvaise qualité et dans un contexte
forte incidence de surpoids l'obésité
plusieurs pays se sont engagés sur des
politiques ambitieuses interdisant la
publicité sur les boissons et aliments à
faible qualité nutritionnelle sur
certains supports ou à certaines
tranches horaires il y a même un
consensus scientifique sur l'utilité de
ce type de politique c'est pourquoi de
matière de manière certes moins
ambitieuse mais en se limitant en
promotion des influenceurs c'est sous
amendement propose interdire les
promotions des boissons avec âge ou de
sucre de sel ou des du Coran et des
aliments transformés je vous remercie
bien on a présenté les trois amendements
discussion commune monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis merci vous
soulignez un point extrêmement important
la question de la promotion des boissons
avec des ajouts de sucre de celles
d'édulcorant de synthèse dans les
produits alimentaires manufacturés nous
y sommes particulièrement sensible c'est
pour cela que nous avons déposé dans
l'article suivant à un amendement enfin
que Monsieur potier a déposé un
amendement
auquel nous donnerons un avis favorable
pour favoriser les messages à caractère
informatif de type manger bouger sur ce
point néanmoins nous ne sommes pas
favorables à un principe d'interdiction
strict à ce stade même si des études
complémentaires pourraient être menées
mais plutôt à cette logique de
prévention voilà donc c'est pour cela
que nous donnerons un avis défavorable
sur ces trois amendements bien je me
permets de faire le lien avec une
audition qu'on a eu hier après-midi et
soir à parler de ce sujet là parce que
les influenceurs qu'on recevait du
disait ce serait quand même dommage de
nous interdire de faire par exemple de
la promotion de Haribo de bonbons alors
que vous permettez de le faire sur tous
les autres canaux de communication c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui rien n'empêche
Michel Édouard Leclerc de faire des pubs
entières sur la promotion du Haribo et
donc en fait ce qui nous disait et
Monsieur rapporteur le dit très bien
c'est qu'on est les mêmes interdictions
ni plus ni moins que les autres cadeaux
mais on va pas s'interdire de faire la
promo de alors que tous les autres
canaux sont ouvertes je me fais
simplement le relais de ce qu'on dit les
influenceurs hier ou alors on se dit
qu'on interdit toute publicité de Haribo
de bonbons mais pour tous les canaux
mais on crée pas une distorsion sur le
sujet mais mais en tout cas c'est je
voulais vous le relier parce que ça a
été un point qui est pas mal fait
discuter hier soir tard dans la nuit sur
le sujet et puis je pense qu'il y a pas
mal de demandes de prise de parole donc
j'ouvre le sujet mais sur cette
discussion donc j'ai madame Amiot
allez-y commencez et merci monsieur le
Président je vous rejoins sur ce que
vous venez de dire
énormément pour nous et un amendement
d'appel dans le sens où effectivement il
est pas question de restreindre plus sur
les réseaux sociaux que sur le reste du
domaine public pour autant il serait
pertinent de réfléchir à l'avenir à
interdire
ce la publicité pour ce type de produit
je pense que tous ici on dit si je vous
dis Haribo vous me répondrez c'est beau
la vie une pause un Kit Kat enfin
aujourd'hui je peux vous citer une
centaine de spots publicitaires qui ont
très bien fait leur effet
nous sommes d'ailleurs en France
tellement sensible à certains produits
que nous sommes les consommateurs
mondiaux les premiers consommateurs
mondial de Nutella par exemple et donc
je pense qu'effectivement il est temps
de réfléchir et de mettre sur la table
la question de la publicité des produits
qui sont enrichis en sucre qui sont trop
gras trop salés trop sucré bien j'ai
madame Duby Muller qui souhait
s'exprimer merci effectivement ces
amendements me paraissent excessif et
aller dans un sens d'une sur
réglementation par rapport aux autres
médias qui utilisent la publicité je
pense que le dispositif proposé par
notre collègue potier m'apparaît plus
pertinent dans le sens où il va vers
plus de prévention vers contre l'obésité
et la lutte contre la sédentarité sur le
sous amendement de Madame Morel j'avais
aussi été interpellé parce que je
rappelle que il y a aujourd'hui des
imperfections sur le nutri-score le coca
zéro et a le Chocapic également donc
cette mesure serait injuste pour un
certain nombre de produits traditionnels
je pense à nos fromages qui font la
fierté de nos terroirs et dont la note
est quasiment des ou e parce qu'il ne
tient pas compte des portions et que par
ailleurs la Commission européenne doit
prochainement proposer la révision du
règlement information du consommateur du
consommateur qui prévoit la mise en
œuvre d'étiquetage harmonisé au niveau
européen donc je pense que ce sous
amendement est un peu à contre-courant
et qu'il est préférable d'attendre
l'examen de ce texte européen très bien
merci Madame bibulaire merci de faire la
promotion de nos terroirs et des
fromages auxquels nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles madame Morel
alizzi juste pour répondre très
rapidement là maintenant que je propose
a quand même été travaillé avec la
Direction générale de la santé et le
professeur Serge herberg qui est
justement l'inventeur du nitriscore
entre autres donc des personnes des
personnels qui suivent ce sujet depuis
longtemps moi j'entends tout à fait le
côté alignement par rapport à
d'autres canaux etc mais il y a aussi le
sujet de dire est-ce que cette loi n'est
pas l'opportunité de mettre un pied dans
la porte pour qu'à terme et ben on
puisse harmoniser sur sur les autres
canaux
très clair monsieur potier soutien
intervenir oui je suis obligé
d'intervenir parce que en cohérence moi
j'aime bien le discours de la cohérence
du président gaz variant si on interdit
pour les influenceurs on interdit
ailleurs et bien justement moi j'entends
l'appel du modèle et des collègues de
EFI et de machin et je et je pense que
cet appel il doit être entendu je vais
leur donner quelques chiffres les amis
quand même pour écouter c'est 800
millions c'est un collègue de c'est un
rapport de Loïc prud'hommes sur
l'agroalimentaire 800 millions sont
ciblés sur la pub à destination des
enfants le diabète T2 c'était je les
chiffres c'était dans notre pays
2% de la population c'est 5,4% 17 ans
après donc sur une bombe à retardement
sanitaire donc est-ce qu'on peut rester
patiemment à dire pas plus un que
l'autre moi j'aime bien votre idée de
pied dans la porte nous allons soutenir
cet amendement avec peu d'espoir mais il
faut que que le débat sur les
influenceurs ouvre la question de la pub
c'est ce que je dis depuis le début au
nom du groupe socialiste la régulation
de la pub n'est pas finie c'est une
question de santé publique qui a une
disproportion telle un rapport de indice
dans les moyens publics et privés sur
l'agroalimentaire sur l'influence alors
vous savez que les premières victimes
c'est les plus pauvres c'est ceux qui
ont pas le bagage culturel qui ont pas
le bagage économique et ceux qui
prennent cher il y a discrimination
sociale en plus de risque on peut dire
c'est une question de liberté il faut
être modéré je pense que c'est un
scandale sanitaire
merci monsieur le Président juste un mot
peut-être sur l'état d'esprit qui va
prévaloir aux quelques amendements là où
on va s'opposer pour le groupe
Renaissance bien sûr que nous comme vous
on est préoccupé par les sujets de santé
publique par les 100 scandales
sanitaires il est important que tous les
messages soient des messages
responsables en particulier pour nos
enfants pour une alimentation saine et
équilibrée en revanche nous préférons
effectivement garder une équité entre la
réglementation la loi pour l'ensemble du
marketing et de la publicité et pour les
influenceurs des réseaux sociaux et
faire comme on en a discuté hier en
table ronde une confiance et un travail
de formation et d'accompagnement aux
influenceurs pour que eux-mêmes
deviennent les véhicules de pratiques
responsable et éthiques en ce sens on
rediscutera tout à l'heure des sujets de
label de certification de la RPP et des
autres mais aujourd'hui les labels sont
très peu pratiqués il faut absolument
que on accompagne les influenceurs à ce
que eux-mêmes et beaucoup sont
exemplaires puissent accompagner nos
jeunes merci
Jo merci je crois que chacun a pu
s'exprimer j'ai monsieur Masseglia bien
sûr monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
masséguy allez-y
moi je m'interroge sur la cohérence de
ces 3 amendements
qu'est-ce qu'on dit avec ces amendements
on dit tout simplement que kameto sur
twitch il n'a plus le droit d'avoir une
bouteille de Red Bull à côté de lui
quand il prend la parole c'est ce qu'on
dit
la personne elle est un twitch elle
allume canal elle met la Formule 1 elle
voit Ricardo qui voit une Red Bull dans
sa voiture Red Bull à un moment donné il
faut un peu de cohérence je suis
d'accord soit en interdit tout soit on
interdit rien mais on peut pas faire une
différence aussi importante en fonction
du média utilisé voilà un appel à la
cohérence n'interdisons pas aux autres
ce que à nous-mêmes on nous interdisons
pas
bien monsieur rapporteur rassurez nous
on va pas tout interdire mais bien sûr
que si cher Président nous allons nous
allons réfléchir en tout cas
collectivement sur la manière de réguler
mieux la publicité et notamment la
publicité liée à l'alimentation parce
que ça a des conséquences majeures
majeures sur la santé publique sur
l'obésité aujourd'hui on voit que
l'obésité est en progression en France
parce que il y a des défauts dans
l'alimentation et la publicité qu'elle
soit à la télévision ou sur les réseaux
sociaux à une influence considérable
donc il faut que le Parlement engage un
travail en ce sens néanmoins c'était pas
l'objet de notre proposition de loi il
s'agissait pas d'ouvrir le champ miné de
la régulation de la publicité pour
l'alimentation nous souhaitons
simplement appliquer à l'influence des
règles qui pèsent sur dans d'autres
secteurs et notamment les messages à
caractère informatif de santé publique
c'est pour cela que je redis que nous
sommes évidemment favorables à
l'amendement potier et que ces
amendements d'appel dont la philosophie
peut être séduisante parce qu'elle
répond à un véritable itable enjeu de
santé publique ne nous semble pas
opportun
je vais donc les mettre voir avec un
avis défavorable du rapporteur qui est
pour
je vais devoir compter cher collègue
donc qui est pour
qui est contre
là c'est très clair il n'est pas adopté
sur le moral 151 qui est pour
quiconque il n'est pas adopté et sur le
cristal 163 qui est pour qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté madame dubymuller
pour le 155
merci monsieur le Président donc c'est
un moment visage à ajouter les produits
contrefaits puisque bien qu'il existe
aujourd'hui des législations en matière
de propriété intellectuelle pour
interdire la détention l'achat et la
vente de contrefaçon il semble opportun
de préciser que la promotion de tels
produits ou la promotion de site vendant
des produits contrefaisants est
également interdite et couverte par la
présente loi
merci alors il y a une identique de
Monsieur Blanchet de 168
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteur mes chers collègues d'abord
je sourcerai cet amendement et la série
d'amendements qui aura sur ce texte
venant de ma part pour éviter de
répétition donc c'est un moment ont été
écrits avec l'Unifab la l'union de
nationale des fabricants de la propriété
intellectuelle et le Knack comité
nationale antique contrefaçon dont je
suis le président
c'est un moment prévoir de comme elle a
été rapporté par ma collègue
précédemment de d'insérer la promotion
des produits contrefaisants aux
interdictions prévues dans l'article
additionnel créé par la rendement 48 des
rapporteurs juste pour vous préciser
deux choses ce qui est interdit en dur
dans des commerces existants doit l'être
aussi dans le monde virtuel c'est le
principe même de de la loi mais en
l'occurrence la contrefaçon et dans le
rapport que nous avions fait il y a deux
ans avec mon collègue perdu Bournazel on
expliquait tout ce qui est controvation
qui n'est pas obligé obligatoirement
dans ce que l'on pense tout de suite
instinctivement va quatre personnes sur
10 qui achètent de la contrefaçon le
font sans le savoir donc ce faux
arnaquer et les influenceurs pourraient
très bien se faire arnaquer en mettant
la promotion de produits donc qui est de
la contrevaçon donc mon amendement
précise de pouvoir rajouter la promotion
des produits contrefaits dans les
interdictions merci beaucoup sur ces
deux sous amendement quelle est la vie
du rapporteur je vous remercie chers
collègues madame Dubi mineur et Monsieur
Blanchet dont je connais l'engagement à
la fois pour la promotion du territoire
du Calvados mais aussi pour contre la
contrefaçon
mais je vous informe que nous avons
l'amendement CE 51
qui me semble plus opérationnel puisque
nous avons intégré dans la vérification
que devait faire l'influenceur lorsqu'il
se livrait à une activité de promotion
commerciale par voie électronique le
fait qu'il ne s'agisse pas de produits
contrefaisant cela étant dit si
l'amendement que nous proposons est
adopté cela permettrait d'éviter de
rappeler finalement des obligations qui
sont déjà existantes et qui ne sont pas
forcément placés au bon endroit dans la
loi c'est pour ça qu'on a une demande de
retrait à défaut un avis défavorable
pour éviter que notre loi soit
redondante et surtout que voilà dans les
obligations qui pèsent aux influenceurs
c'est la vérification que le produit
n'est pas contrefaisant et non pas voilà
l'interdiction brute parce que
finalement ça n'a pas grand sens
bien y a-t-il des demandes
d'intervention monsieur Blanchet allez-y
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur j'apprécie votre réponse mais
je maintiendrai mon amendement parce que
déjà il est passé avant le vôtre donc il
est légitimité pouvoir être voté et si
tant bien je le fais aussi que le vôtre
soit voté après bon on arrangera se
lancer en séance mais je vous propose de
laisser ça non parce que mettre la
lumière sur la contrefaçon c'est le
moment avec les influenceurs qui ont
vraiment une possibilité de nuisance
comme d'informations aussi pour
impliquer nos jeunes à une bonne
information et pas que les jeunes le
monde des adultes aussi donc je le
maintiendrai monsieur le rapporteur
merci et madame dubuiseur vous souhaitez
le vous le retirer d'accord
alors non les deux comme ils sont
identiques là les deux si les deux sont
adoptés
non
non ça n'est pas le cas il sera présent
vous souhaitiez préciser quelque chose
non mais j'entends ce que dit collègue
Blanchet c'est un signal mais j'aurais
aimé que nous envoyions d'autres signaux
et j'espère que vous soutiendrez en
séance quand on réécrira les amendements
notamment sur les produits de santé et
sur l'interdiction des jeux d'argent
vous soutiendrez aussi ces amandes qui
sont importants c'est pour ça que je
vais donner un avis de sagesse sur
celui-ci parce que c'est un signal qui
est envoyé et plus les signaux sont
nombreux plus les voyants sont rouges
meilleurs se portera le secteur
d’influence alors attendez donc il y a
un avis de sagesse finalement donc
madame dubuiseur vous êtes que vous le
maintenez du coup
d'accord
maintiens son amendement c'est un avis
de sagesse sur les deux amendements
identiques je le mets donc au vois avec
un avis de sagesse qui est pour
je vais compter excusez-moi
oui bah là ça paraît clair d'accord donc
qui est contre
ils sont adoptés
nous passons au 187 de Madame Amiot
oui merci monsieur le Président par cet
amendement on nous souhaitons protéger
les enfants des pratiques des parents
influenceurs en s'assurant que les
enfants de moins de 16 ans ne puissent
être utilisés
dans des contenus abus commercial sans
autorisation individuelle préalable
accordée par l'autorité administrative
dans son rapport sur les parents
influenceurs en février 2023
l'Observatoire de la parentalité de
l'éducation numérique révèle que 85% des
parents influenceurs publient des
contenus de leurs enfants
au moins une fois par semaine et que
seulement 44% des parents déclarent
obtenir le consentement de l'enfant
avant de publier du contenu le
concernant
si cela représente déjà une atteinte au
respect du droit à l'image de l'enfant
cela va plus loin puisque 60% des
parents déclarent jusqu'à une heure de
temps de préparation et que deux
et que deux à 10 prises de vue sont
nécessaires avant la publication quel
que soit le format photo ou vidéo
cette nouvelle forme d'activité
professionnelle doit être encadrée et
Rui goureusement et plus rigoureusement
et que les parents influenceurs doivent
se plier au dispositif de protection des
enfants existant et s'appliquant
notamment dans nos activités du cinéma
et du spectacle
merci monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues dans la même ligne que les
discussions que nous avons eu
précédemment j'estime que les
amendements que nous avons adopté ce
jour qui permettent de d'appliquer la
loi Studer à l'influence en ligne me
semble satisfaisant et un moment il
proposait d'élargir évidemment on n'est
pas défavorable sur le principe mais je
préférerais qu'on en reste là s'il vous
plaît donc une demande de retrait
d'accord est-ce qu'il est maintenu il
est maintenu je vais donc le mettre au
bout avec un avis défavorable du
rapporteur qui est pour qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté je continue avec le
masse et glia le 157
merci monsieur le Président j'ai vu que
mon collègue Blanchet gagné des voies en
disant de qui venait l'amendement alors
celui-là il vient de la rue il vient du
terrain il vient des rencontres que je
fais
qu'est-ce que je veux dire on est en
train de faire une PPL transpartisan et
j'espère bien que chacun d'entre nous
pourra avoir des victoires dessus sinon
elle sera pas transpartisane mais bon
enfin voilà l'objet de cet amendement
est très simple en fait il y a une série
qui sort sur Youtube tous les mois
toutes les semaines excusez-moi qui
s'appelle dans la tête d'un pro c'est on
suit un influenceur une personne qui
joue au poker qui appartient à une
structure et qui réalise des
compétitions et qui explique lors de ses
compétitions quelle est sa réflexion
comment il réfléchit et quelles sont ses
objectifs
avec la PPL qu'elle est écrite
aujourd'hui ce type de contenu serait
interdit je pense que on sort du cadre
qui est l'objectif initial de la PPL qui
est de lutter contre les escroqueries
contre l'usage de certaines méthodes
pour vendre des produits là c'est plutôt
la Vendée de dire lorsque une personne
certes a une rémunération mais qui ne
fait pas de la promotion directe alors
il pourra éventuellement proposer des
contenus qui ont une visée alors c'est
pas forcément de pédagogique mais plutôt
de permettre aux personnes de progresser
dans tel ou telle passion dans tel ou
telle activité
bien monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
oui merci il me semble que les gamers
qui participent à des événements ne sont
pas concernés par le champ de la loi
donc c'est un avis défavorable il y a
pas c'est pas de contributs de
contrepartie économique ou en nature
l'influenceur n'entre pas dans le cadre
fixé par la présente
dans le cas présent dans la tête d'un
pro ce n'est en aucun cas du gaming
je remarque que vous me
remettez comme le référent sur le sujet
mais là je parle de pratique de type
poker qui est totalement différent du
gaming dans la tête d'un pro c'est
soutenu par une entreprise française
dont je ne fais pas publicité mais qui
commence par oui qui finit par axe et
dans lequel il y a des joueurs français
qui partent aux États-Unis et qui se
filment en train de faire une
compétition en expliquant les décisions
qu'ils ont prises donc ça n'est
strictement rien à voir avec le jeu
vidéo mais c'est plutôt par contre un
outil qui permette aux personnes de se
dire cette réflexion là me permettra de
progresser sur ma façon de jouer au
poker c'est pour ça que je suis le sujet
et aujourd'hui avec votre PPL ça devient
interdit
bien donc ça voudrait dire que je
comprenne bien si vous faites du poker
vous allez vous êtes un influenceur qui
bosse sur le poker si vous allez un
événement de poker vous proposez de ne
pas interdire enfin de ne pas interdire
l'influence associé à ça si vous faites
pas la promotion du produit qui est
vendu par l'événement c'est exactement
ça en fait dans la série mais ça peut
être plein d'autres sujets si les
personnes se filment en train de jouer
au poker en faisant ma stratégie c'est
ça mais sans dire c'est super bien le
poker et surtout aller chez Winamax et
je souhaite qu'on laisse autoriser par
contre si la personne dit le poker c'est
super bien allez-y mettez du pognon et
surtout mettez-vous chez Winamax ça il
faut qu'on interdise c'est vraiment la
construction d'un compromis qui puisse
continuer à faire des vidéos sur le
poker tout en ne faisant pas la
promotion d'une entité commerciale
particulière ok c'est bon monsieur le
rapporteur soutien intervenir allez-y
j'entends ce que vous dites chers
collègues alors je vous avoue que ça
peut être un effet de bord qui convient
de réduire je vous propose qu'on en
discute en vue de la séance parce que
voilà c'est ça je suis pas exactement
convaincu par votre rédaction je pense
qu'il faut qu'on simplifie ça et il
reste toujours la possibilité des
exceptions prévues par décret qui vise
justement à éviter ces effets de bord
qui serait indésirables donc voilà ça
sera plutôt une demande de retrait bien
je crois qu'on est Monsieur
laissant le et puis on modifiera dans
l'hémicycle
allez on avance je crois qu'on est
éclairé par ce dialogue je vous propose
de le mettre au voie avec un avis donc
défavorable du rapporteur qui est pour
qui compte il n'est pas adopté j'ai
l'amendement 180 monsieur est-ce que
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur chers collègues un petit
effet de répétition pour ceux qui auront
suivi mais c'est pas grave je demande
l'indulgence du tribunal ce sous
abonnement a pour but de préciser la
possibilité de majorer le montant de
l'amende encourue par une influenceur
pour le non-respect des interdictions de
promotion mentionnée à cet article cette
mort à jour majoration pour alors
atteindre 100% du montant du prix de la
promotion afin d'apporter un caractère
véritablement dissuasif à l'interdiction
le Président chers collègues ça la
rédaction actuelle nous paraît plutôt
équilibrée on a cherché à obtenir un
principe de proportionnalité et avec la
peine complémentaire qu'on vous propose
aussi d'adopter ça nous paraît
suffisamment dissuasif là le risque
c'est que ça soit sur les amendes assez
importante ou faible finalement puisque
si vous avez touché peu d'argent alors
vous avez fait une publicité extrêmement
grave mettons que vous ayez touché 500
euros voilà une amende de 500 euros
c'est pas suffisant si vous avez fait
voilà quelque chose d'extrêmement grave
donc ça voilà c'est pas c'est pas adapté
bien vous le maintenez très bien pas
d'intervention je le mets aux voix avec
un invité favorable du rapporteur qui
est pour qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté nous avons madame en grand vous
propose de 136 oui alors les peines
prévues nous sommes incomplète au regard
de la variété des infractions possibles
et de leur intensité imprimer imposer
une peine fixe c'est mettre sur un pied
d'égalité l'influenceur un peu maladroit
et malhabile avec la loi et
l'influenceur qui abuserait et ont été
membre de son audience c'est pourquoi
cet amendement propose que des peines
infligées aux influenceurs qui fraudent
soit plus lourdes lorsque les victimes
sont des personnes en état d'ignorance
ou de faiblesse au sens du Code pénal et
selon que ces abus soient organisés ou
non merci je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur de votre avis
merci monsieur le Président ça sera un
avis défavorable il convient de
respecter le principe de
proportionnalité des dédiés et des
peines et par ailleurs le juge peut
toujours choisir de requalifier si il
s'avère que les personnes sont en
situation de faiblesse et qui a un abus
de faiblesse manifeste donc voilà
défavorable et peine proportionnelle
bien je vais donc mettre avec un avis
défavorable du rapporteur qui est pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté je vais
donc mettre voix l'amendement du
rapporteur le 48 qui donc a été sous
amendé par le 197 de Madame spielboot le
200 de Madame givernais le 155 de Madame
dubymuller le 168 de Monsieur Blanchet
je vais donc mettre au bois cet
amendement ainsi sous amendée qui est
pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
nous continuons avec le 49 de Monsieur
Delaporte réactionnel je mets on voit
qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
amendement faisant l'objet d'un de
plusieurs années
même principe on les voit un par un bon
monsieur de la porte pour le 50 allez-y
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement ils vise à compléter la
rédaction initiale qui avait été
envisagée relative à la promotion des
influenceurs par des influenceurs pardon
dans le cadre d'une activité d'influence
commerciale par voie électronique des
offres de formation professionnelle
ainsi que des contenus ayant fait
l'objet de retouche via un logiciel de
traitement je précise que notamment la
formation professionnelle a été
travaillée en lien avec le ministère
concerné ce nouvel article prévoit
d'abord que toutes les promotions de
produits par les personnes mentionnées
articles le premier de la présente-toi
doivent être indiqués par une mention
claire lisible
identifiable sur l'image sur l'image ou
la vidéo durant l'intégralité de la
promotion c'est ce que prévoit par
ailleurs le DSA il s'agit de lutter
contre les publicités déguisées ou
subreptis c'est amendement propose
également comme je l'ai indiqué que pour
la publicité relative aux formations
professionnelles soit mentionnées le nom
de l'organisme de formation à l'origine
de la publicité donc des règles de
transparence ainsi que celui référencé
sur mon compte formation en cas de
sous-traitance lorsque la publicité de
l'influenceur porte sur des formations
éligibles au CPF on l'a vu hier soir la
lutte enfin la diffusion des fausses
formations des mauvaises formations et
des abus sont à un sujet important c'est
affichage il permettra donc de
responsabiliser les organismes de
formation et d'autre part à la Caisse
des Dépôts consignations de pouvoir
diligenter le cas échéant et contrôle
auprès de l'organisme de formation
responsable de la publicité et éligible
au financement CPF cet amendement et ce
n'est pas un de ces moindres sujets
propose également que les contenus créés
et diffusés par des personnes
mentionnées à l'article 1er donc les
influenceurs exerçant l'activité
d'influence commerciale comprenant des
images ayant fait l'objet d'une
modification par un logiciel de
traitement d'image doivent être
accompagnés de la mention image
retouchée cela permettra notamment de
lutter contre les stéréotypes la
diffusion des stéréotypes de genre qui
posent aussi des sujets importants voilà
et enfin on prévoit une pour que pour
toute violation y est une des peines
d'un entrepreneur et de 4500 euros
d'amende
très bien nous allons passer à la toute
la série de sous-amendements même
principe que tout à l'heure je mets aux
voix amendement à partir du moment le
137 madame en grand OUI quelques mots
simplement pour cet amendement
rédactionnel imposer la condition de
réalisation nous semble superflus un
influenceur peut réaliser toutes les
promotions qui le veut s'il ne les
diffusent jamais il ne fait rien
d'illégal bien sûr de même s'il ne
réalise pas ses promotions mais diffuse
des promotions réalisées par la marque
qui leur est mineure est-ce qu'il passe
outre du cadre imposé par cette
rédaction afin d'éviter à nos juges
d'inutile ne au cerveau il conviendrait
comme le prévoit cet amendement de
préférer le critère de diffusion merci
je vous remercie l'avis du rapporteur
avis défavorable je vais donc le mettre
avec un avis défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté madame en
grand le 138
cet amendement étant la liste des
supports promotionnels qui doivent moi
qui doivent mentionner leurs caractères
promotionnel au support audio et textuel
en effet les moyens employés par les
influenceurs pour promouvoir un produit
ne sont pas strictement au visuels bien
que cela soit évidemment la solution
privilégiée toutefois nous ne sommes pas
à l'abri d'une évolution des méthodes
employées pour faire la promotion d'un
produit l'essor d'espèces sur Twitter
doit nous inciter à étendre ces
interdictions au support audio de la
même façon les influenceurs sont parfois
des administrateurs de groupe
semi-publique qu'ils organisent-ils
organisent sur des applications telles
que discord où ils peuvent alors faire
la promotion
à l'aide donc de d'hyperliants à un
cercle privilégié de leur public qui
sera d'autant plus enclin à acheter par
l'illusion de proximité que va créer ce
type de groupe le but de cet amendement
est donc est d'éviter le contournement
de la loi par des méthodes de promotion
aujourd'hui marginales mais susceptible
de se développer pour pallier les
contraintes opposées par la présente
proposition de loi merci merci
défavorable je mets donc on va avec un
avis défavorable du rapporteur qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
monsieur espionnegox pour le 175 merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur collègue ce sous
amendement mise à ajouter un message de
prévention en amont des publicités en
plus des mentions obligatoires que vous
avez bien voulu substituer au bandeau
qui sont mal perçus par les créateurs de
contenu par ce sous-amendement nous
viendrons ainsi compléter le dispositif
écrit d'avertissement par une mise en
garde orale directement par le créateur
de contenu celui-ci sera diffusé
immédiatement avant le message
publicitaire ou promotionnel merci
bien monsieur rapporteur
ça nous semble un peu trop contraignant
l'amendement que nous avons travaillé a
été rédigé avec les résultats issus des
concertations de Bercy c'est ce qui nous
paraissait proportionné à applicable
donc ça sera un avis défavorable bien
vous le maintenez il est maintenu je
vais donc vous voyez avec un avis
défavorable du rapporteur qui est pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
madame a mis au excusez-moi le 192 oui
merci Monsieur le président il s'agit
par ce sous amendement de compléter la
formulation de d'ajouter non seulement
la dénomination commerciale dénomination
sociale excusez-moi par le numéro de
sirène lorsqu'il s'agit notamment de
d'organismes de formation lorsqu'il
s'agit de faire la promotion
d'organismes de formation je sais pas si
vous le savez mais aujourd'hui deux
organismes de formation peuvent porter
le même nom et d'ailleurs c'est un des
problèmes qu'on rencontrait des des
victimes de d'arnaque aux faux
organismes de formation ainsi que ainsi
que la DGCCRF qui a été bien en peine de
retrouver des des fausses organismes de
formation parce que ceci portait des
noms similaires à d'autres parfaitement
en règle aujourd'hui le seul moyen enfin
les organismes de formation sont
identifiés par le numéro de déclaration
d'activité le NDA rattacher à une
personne morale c'est-à-dire le numéro
de SIREN donc ce que nous vous proposons
c'est tout simplement que dans les dans
le descriptif de la vidéo apparaissent
ce numéro de sirène lorsqu'il s'agit de
faire la promotion d'un organisme de
formation pour être certain que cette
organisme de formation soit sain et ça à
la fois ça protège les consommateurs les
organismes de formation qui sont en
règle et ça permet d'identifier
facilement les contrevenants je vous
remercie monsieur rapporteur oui j'ai
pas d'avis spécial donc ça sera un avis
de sagesse bon faut pas renforcer les
règles mais pourquoi pas mais je suis
pas sûr que tout c'est un numéro de
série
pardon OK
donc c'est un avis favorable du
rapporteur sous la maman de Madame Amyot
le 192 qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
j'ai monsieur petit qui propose de 132
132 monsieur potier oui j'ai bien j'ai
bien j'écoutais je sais j'ai laissé la
le ressentiment de ma collègue
s'exprimer oui la population française
aujourd'hui c'est une personne sur deux
en surpoids et une sur 6 Obs j'ai donné
des chiffres sur le diabète T2 et son
terrifiants quelques autres la
consommation d'aliments de mauvaise
qualité nutritionnelle augmente de 61 %
le risque de maladies cardiovasculaires
de 40% le syndrome métabolique et de
plus de 60% le risque d'obésité chez
l'homme le coût global de la malbouffe
dépasse les 50 milliards par an on était
à 19 milliards sur le diabète T2 et
c'est pour ces raisons majeures de santé
publique mais également d'équilibre de
nos comptes de sécurité sociale qu'une
politique de prévention doit se mettre
en oeuvre l'OMS le ministère de la Santé
l'ancêtre tout le monde est favorable
donc cet abonnement il dit simplement on
applique aux influenceurs les règles qui
prévalent pareil pour les aliments ça
les gras ça les sucré et édulcorant et
bien il y a ces il y a le nutri-score et
des prévues par la loi et puis il y a
pour les boissons
surrées il y a tous les dispositifs
d'alerte sur le fait du sport manger
autrement etc vivez mieux c'est vraiment
je le dis c'est vraiment le minimum
encore une fois on a mené parfois des
combats plus durs mais on joue le jeu de
se compromis transpartisan c'est
amendement et l'abonnement minimum
attendu comme pour le reste de la pub au
minimum on prévient on sait que ça
suffit pas pour des gamins les plus
défavorisés mais au moins on fait ça
ce que vous pouvez présenter le wesh
comment conserve vous avez présenté
aussi le 193 en discussion commune parce
que ils sont très très proche monsieur
potier mais sinon je vous redonne la
parole pour le défendre en même temps je
comptais je comptais j'attendais la vie
des rapports
sur les deux pas de problème donc
allez-y j'ai cru comprendre que il y
avait des problèmes techniques plus que
politique sur le nutri-score dans
l'application la mise en oeuvre et pas
et pas totalement satisfaisante et que à
la demande je crois de de du
gouvernement vous êtes plutôt sur une
logique de pas mettre une nutriscore et
de garder toutes les autres allégations
de santé publique sauf le nutriscor moi
je le regrette et mais ça m'invite
humblement à retravailler sur
l'application d'une nutri-score
aujourd'hui dans notre pays qui me
semble plutôt être un progrès alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'il est pas bien mis
en oeuvre pourquoi ça posera un problème
j'entends que ça demande un
approfondissement et je suis prêt à
retirer ce premier amendement monsieur
le Président au bénéfice du second qui
je sais à la sentiment à la fois du
gouvernement et des rapporteurs mais je
propose que en séance comme pour les
questions posées par nos collègues de
les filles ici et là qui étaient
techniques et de est vraiment
constructif on se on se prépare dans la
dans les semaines qui viennent à avoir
un chorus plus important et aller plus
loin possible monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur rapporteur votre avis donc sur
les deux amendements merci Monsieur
potier pour votre sagesse et votre
proposition de retirer le premier
amendement en effet le nitriscorn nous
nous semblait pas après discussion avec
les autorités compétentes totalement
adaptées et juridiquement applicable
donc voilà nous avons souhaité vous
remercier par ailleurs pour avoir
travaillé cet amendement qui nous permet
d'aller dans le bon sens et de mieux
lutter contre les objectifs que vous
avez rappelé que nous avons évoqué tout
à l'heure de santé publique et de lutte
contre la malbouffe
j'ai juste une question à poser allez-y
monsieur potier mais j'avais juste une
question à poser avant sur le donc c'est
en fait vous dites le défavorable sur
132 au profit du 193 et une question que
vous connaissez mon mon amour de la
cohérence monsieur potier est-ce que les
interdits enfin les demandes que vous
mettez là
d'informations
elle va aussi pour d'autres canaux que
les influenceurs
sur le fait qu'on interdit pas aux
influenceurs de la cohérence et de la
justice j'espère et donc c'est les mêmes
c'est les mêmes canaux voilà l'extension
du nitriscore
autorités qui sont pas ultra libérales
ou qui défendent des intérêts privés
nous disent c'est compliqué donc moi
j'entends je veux bien approfondir le
sujet on l'a appris hier soir ce matin
voilà bon donc je retire dans un esprit
constructif le 132 au bénéfice du 193 et
je voulais simplement en deux secondes
rendre hommage à Guillaume Garraud
président de la Commission nationale de
l'alimentation qui avec moi travailler
ses amendements et les soutiens vivement
c'est le sens de toutes les
préconisations de la CRU mythologie
santé publique alimentation qui est
défendue par lui à travers cette
amendement bien donc vous avez retiré le
un des deux amendements et donc c'est le
193 que vous retenez et qui
et qui a un avis favorable donc du
rapporteur je vais donc le mettre au
bout avec un avis favorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
nous continuons avec le cristal 160
merci monsieur le Président lorsque
j'étais rapporteur du projet de loi
d'adultes j'ai eu à traiter la question
des denrées alimentaires et j'étais
interpellé par la dérive de la vente des
compléments alimentaires sur internet et
sur les réseaux sociaux en raison de ces
nouveaux canaux de vente souvent via les
influenceurs la consommation des
compléments alimentaires à doubler ces
dernières années alors qu'une seule
infime partie de la population en a
réellement besoin et que la consommation
est la surconsommation promue sur les
réseaux sociaux peut avoir des effets
secondaires y compris des effets
secondaires graves cela fait des années
que l'ancêtre et les académies de
médecine et de pharmacie alerte sur ce
point c'est pourquoi je vous propose que
la promotion de compléments alimentaires
doivent obligatoirement être accompagnés
d'un message à caractère sanitaire
rappelant les dangers liés leur
consommation je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis
merci votre sous-amendement qui propose
d'inclure les compléments alimentaires
dans l'obligation de la formation
concernant les produits alimentaires
faisant l'objet de la part des
influenceurs va encore une fois dans le
sens de ce que nous souhaitons
collectivement portrait néanmoins ce
serait une demande de retrait parce que
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
ce sujet peut-être le redéposer en
séance pour aboutir à une rédaction qui
convient à tous
oui
nous allons soutenir cet amendement qui
va dans le sens de ce que nous avons pu
déposer et qui sont tombés précédemment
dans l'article 1
je souhaitais insister je sais pas si
vous le savez chers collègues mais
certains certains compléments
alimentaires notamment par exemple les
protéines un excès de protéines peut
vous détruire les reins un excès de
certaines de certaines vitamines peut
vous détruire le foie peuvent vous
détruire la rate ou atteindre votre
cerveau et quand je dis atteindre votre
cerveau c'est produire des dégâts sur
votre cerveau
pourtant il s'agit que de vitamines
qu'on retrouve sur les paquets de
céréales on vous dit que ce paquet de
céréales et du moins ces céréales sont
enrichies en vitamine A B D etc
on a l'impression que les vitamines
c'est vraiment super méga top et que ou
que le les compléments
en métaux en fer en magnésium c'est
vraiment ce dont on a besoin en
permanence en réalité il faut comme pour
toute chose que ce soit d'oser que ce
soit avec parcimonie et seulement en cas
de besoin les compléments alimentaires
devraient à mon sens être prescrit par
des médecins et être suivis par des
médecins ou des nutritionnistes en cas
de de évidemment de carence mais la
carence elle s'accompagne et elle se
détecte par la profession médicale donc
il me paraît réellement important
effectivement qu'on est conscience que
promouvoir
certains compléments alimentaires qui
peuvent paraître anodins en réalité
peuvent
détruire certains de nos organes et pour
aller jusqu'à la mort pour certains
bien sûr rapporteur
vous lui répondre et puis ensuite
Monsieur Madame Christol allez-yves
rapporteur oui je souhaiterais quand
même pouvoir travailler ce sujet parce
que en oncologie aussi on a beaucoup de
doutes sur la surconsommation ces
compléments alimentaires dans
l'évolution du cancer et également dans
les interactions avec des traitements en
chimiothérapie donc si vous me confirmez
que d'ici le dépôt pour la séance de
main nous pouvons retravailler une
nouvelle rédaction moi je veux bien le
retirer mais j'ai vraiment le porter en
séance
ma question que je pose à chaque fois
mais je pense c'est important de la
poser est-ce que sur cette interdiction
on peut avoir un sujet sur les
compléments alimentaires mais si ça vaut
pour les influenceurs ça vaut également
pour les spots télé ça vaut pour les
spots radio ça vaut pour le papier ça
vaut pour tous les sujets pour les
affiches pour le pour tout donc ma
question est ce que sur ce sujet là on
va plus loin ou pas pour les
influenceurs que sur les autres canaux
de publicité je sais juste d'avoir la
réponse sur ça mais sur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président pour votre
interrogation qui a le mérite de pointer
le véritable sujet de la loi qui nous
concerne les influenceurs aujourd'hui
c'est pas de la publicité qui est faite
n'importe enfin c'est plutôt de la
publicité qui peut être faite n'importe
comment par n'importe qui et c'est ça
qui distingue la publicité
sur les réseaux sociaux de la publicité
de manière générale dans les autres
canaux de communication c'est pour cela
aussi que nous avons discuté tout à
l'heure de l'interdiction de la
publicité pour les jeux d'argent et les
paris sportifs parce que aujourd'hui
quand on discute avec la NJ on voit très
bien que la publicité pour les les jeux
d'argent elle est extrêmement régulée
mais aussi ici on doit faire l'objet de
dépôt je prends cet exemple là auprès de
la NJ des différentes campagnes or
aujourd'hui on est dans l'impossibilité
face à la multiplicité des producteurs
de contenu face à la multiplicité des
contenus de tout pouvoir vérifier de
tout pouvoir Internet et par ailleurs il
y a une disposition qui peut s'appliquer
pour réguler spécifiquement certains
secteurs qui est lié à des motifs de
santé publique et ça c'est le second
élément qui a fait que l'Espagne
notamment a été plus loin sur le sujet
c'est que pour des raisons de santé
publique on voit bien que les
influenceurs ont un impact plus
conséquent qu'un simple message
publicitaire si je fais une pub pour les
dragées arrivent pour reprendre ce sujet
là
si je suis
voilà quelqu'un d'extrêmement reconnu et
connu je vais pas avoir le même impact
que madame tout le monde que vous ne
connaissez pas et ça c'est ce qui peut
justifier des interdictions spécifiques
pour des motifs de santé publique quand
on a un impact particulier majeur sur la
santé publique et on l'a vu hier soir
sur les compléments alimentaires c'est
un sujet majeur
les différentes vigie nous disaient
citoyennes nous disaient que ça faisait
partie des sujets qui remontaient de
partout c'est ce que dit également la
mi-vilud c'est ce que dit le ministère
de la Santé la Direction générale de la
santé donc voilà on a un sujet et Madame
Christol madame Amiot long pointé de
manière active sur ces compléments
alimentaires néanmoins voilà je trouve
que la rédaction n'est pas assez abouti
mais il faut absolument qu'on arrive à
trouver la bonne formulation d'ici la
séance pour aboutir à une régulation
efficace de la publicité pour les
compléments alimentaires parce que c'est
l'un des sujets qui aujourd'hui restent
flous dans notre droit et qui devrait
faire l'objet d'une attention spécifique
de notre part monsieur leur aventure ce
sujet là comme sur les autres parce que
il y a un sujet sur les compléments
alimentaires il y a un sujet sur
l'alcool il y a un sujet sur le sucre il
y a un sujet sur le gras il y a un sujet
sur les jeux vidéo il y a un sujet sur
les jeux en ligne et un sujet sur le les
jeux d'argent mais la vocation de votre
PPL tel que je la comprends et tel que
je la soutiens tel que nous la soutenons
en tout cas je la soutiens je m'écris à
titre personnel mais c'est pas la
volonté c'est d'appliquer aux
influenceurs une réglementation qui
existe pour les autres et après si il y
a besoin de renforcer sur les
compléments alimentaires à ce moment là
on fait une proposition de loi visant à
renforcer quel que soit le canal parce
que si c'est dangereux de ce côté-là
côté influenceur ça l'est aussi côté
papier là sur les compléments
alimentaires je vous prends un exemple
moi j'ai un producteur de spiruline ok
c'est agriculteur il fait de la
spiruline donc pourquoi est-ce que si je
considère qu'il y a un sujet sur la
promotion de la spiruline il faudrait
que je distingue la partie promotion via
l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux
versus la partie promotion via des
prospectus ou des affiches ou des
pancartes ou que sais-je comme moyen de
promotion si on veut réglementer les
compléments alimentaires à ce moment-là
on fait une réglementation spécifique
complément alimentaire c'est ça que
j'essaie de dire parce que sinon on
prend deux risques le risque c'est de
surréglementer pour des influenceurs des
choses qu'on a réglement pas par
ailleurs l'autre risque c'est de passer
à côté d'un vrai problème potentiel
parce que s'il y a vraiment un problème
sur les compléments alimentaires à ce
moment là il faut faire une vraie
proposition de loi sur les compléments
alimentaires et les messages sanitaires
associés quel que soit le canal sinon on
aborde que la toute petite partie qui
est l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est tout ce que j'essaye de le dire
mais c'est vrai que moi je suis attaché
à la cohérence et au fait de bien
comprendre à chaque fois si nos
interdictions qu'elle va être leur
regard et leur impact réel madame
givernais vous souhaitiez vous
intervenir madame Morel aussi oui
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez raison on peut
parler également des jeux d'argent parce
que c'est un secteur où là c'est très
très régulier au niveau de la publicité
je tiens à rappeler qu'il y a
effectivement une demande sur les
opérateurs de fournir un plan de
publicité chaque année à la NJ ça doit
être pareil sur sur les autres secteurs
et c'est bien aux opérateurs
fournisseurs du service ou des produits
qui doivent eux-mêmes justifier de la
publicité qu'il en fait c'est pas les
canaux ni TF1 ni autre qui doivent
justifier en fait que l'annonce et la
publicité et la communication autour de
leur produit soit dans les clous donc
moi pour moi les influenceurs sont un
canal ils ont aussi une éthique et je
pense qu'il faut aussi travailler de ce
sens dans ce sens là mais encore une
fois lorsqu' fourni un produit ou un
service c'est bien assez fournisseurs
qu'il faut incomber la la responsabilité
madame Morel oui pour merci monsieur le
Président pour répondre à votre remarque
pour moi la réflexion elle est plutôt
est-ce que on s'aligne vers le haut ou
est-ce qu'on s'aligne bien vers le bas
bien sûr il faut être cohérent entre les
différents réseaux c'est ce qu'on disait
avant mais il faut pas oublier quand
même que là le thème est si nos émeuts
aussi tout simplement c'est parce que il
est pas anodin notamment pour les jeunes
on a 95% des 16 25 ans qui fréquentent
quotidiennement les réseaux sociaux 87%
des acheteurs sur les réseaux sociaux
disent que ce qui passe par les réseaux
sociaux bien entendu et les influenceurs
influencent leur comportement d'achat
donc on est face à des chiffres qui sont
massifs et il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
publicité qu'elle soit papier qu'elle
soit télévisée peut-être et moins les
plus jeunes d'entre nous donc est-ce
qu'on met un pied dans la porte ou pas
pour justement se dire que par la suite
on s'appuiera sur d'autres textes de loi
pour harmoniser ou non
que vient ce que vient de dire la
collègue donc je pense qu'il est il est
pertinent aussi d'envisager la
possibilité de mettre le pied dans la
porte et de ce de nous faciliter par la
suite le travail de législateur en
estimant qu'effectivement on peut on
peut sortir par le haut et étendre
étendre ses restrictions ou ses droits
à l'ensemble à l'ensemble des des
supports de publicité on l'a dit tout à
l'heure il est peut-être grand temps de
remettre la question sur la table de la
loi Eva et de sa base à savoir comment
on protège les gens des addictions et
peut-être d'interdire de songer
l'interdiction des publicités sur tout
ce qui génère des addictions
on me fait remarquer effectivement il y
a peut-être aussi un sujet
constitutionnel après d'égalité après on
pourra en discuter mais le le fait de
pas mettre sur le même plan et le la
même égalité des règles différentes pour
des acteurs qui font de la promotion et
la publicité c'est une rupture d'égalité
donc je peux tout à fait y avoir ensuite
une question de constitué qui se pose
mais
je l'entends d'autres interventions
madame spielbout allez-y oui juste
peut-être puisque c'est un sujet vous
avez raison qui nous aimait tous au
regard de
la portée très forte et du rayonnement
de tous ces conseils en santé et en
alimentation qui qui ferait sur les
réseaux sociaux peut-être que c'est dans
la partie où on parle du contrat et on a
un certain nombre d'amendements
messieurs les rapporteurs pour étoffer
les contrats entre les agences
d'influenceurs et les influenceurs ou
entre les marques et les influenceurs
c'est peut-être là comme on propose
d'informer sur le certificat d'influence
responsable où il faut indiquer une
obligation
de d'informations et de responsabilité
éthique sur un certain nombre de chances
c'est peut-être sur le sujet statut
contrat qu'on pourra approfondir d'ici
la séance si vous le souhaitez
bien je crois qu'on est éclairé sur le
sujet monsieur le rapportera allez-y oui
je on est sur la sur l'un des sujets
importants enfin c'est parce que cette
conversation sur cette discussion sur
les compléments alimentaires en fait
elle permet d'évoquer quelques principes
plus généraux de notre droit à savoir
est-ce que pour des canaux différents de
communication on peut avoir des règles
différentes et la réponse est oui si on
regarde la loi Eva qui pour moi est
l'exemple d'une belle loi et c'était
rappelé tout à l'heure par Monsieur
Girardin qui peut nécessiter quelques
évolutions et à des réflexions en ce
moment sur l'évolution de la loi Eva
mais aujourd'hui elle prévoit par
exemple des interdictions monsieur le
Président spécifique à la télévision
c'est à dire que il y a des heures qui
sont régulées il y a des médias qui sont
interdits et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
prévu ces interdictions spécifiques et
pourquoi c'est constitutionnel parce que
il y a un principe supérieur qui
s'appelle la protection de la santé
publique la protection des mineurs c'est
ce qui a justifié certaines
interdictions et donc si on part des
principes qui ont guidé à l'édiction de
la loi Eva et qu'on les étend au moins
philosophiquement symboliquement à
d'autres sujets on peut considérer que
lorsque on a des mineurs et publics
vulnérables et notamment personne ne
pourra dire le contraire que l'influence
commerciale en ligne elle touche
incidament mais énormément les mineurs
et que on ne peut pas restreindre
aujourd'hui de manière effective l'accès
au contenu aux mineurs et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que Monsieur Studer
travaille aussi beaucoup sur le sujet et
donc on a nécessité de pouvoir renforcer
certaines interdictions mais c'est comme
ça aussi qu'on a construit la loi on a
mis et je vous remercie collègues
d'avoir voté l'article premier bis et
l'article premier terme l'article
premier bis il rappelle que les régimes
d'interdiction généraux s'appliquent aux
influenceurs c'est ce qu'on a commencé
par voter et notamment la loi Eva et
derrière l'article premier terme il
précise un certain nombre
d'interdictions parce que on voit que le
droit actuel est flou sur un certain
nombre de points et que notre loi elle
vient combler les lacunes du droit et en
particulier on a évoqué la chirurgie
esthétique tout à l'heure on voit bien
que pour la formation professionnelle il
y a des flous il y a nécessité d'avancer
on ne peut pas se dire que on continue
de réguler à trois constants parce qu'il
y a ce principe de canaux différents et
je finirai en disant que l'influenceur
ne fait pas de la publicité classique
aujourd'hui la publicité c'est des
agences c'est des gens qui sont formés
c'est en lien avec les marques et qui
est il y a un contrôle assez strict sur
le contenu qui est produit
aujourd'hui
l'influenceur ça peut être n'importe qui
du mystère l'influenceur finalement
diplôme d'état en fait il y a quand même
une réglementation qui pèse sur le
secteur de la publicité qui est
important et aujourd'hui on peut pas
dire que l'influenceur ça soit ça peut
être vous comme moi et ça peut être une
activité accessoire c'est pas forcément
votre métier et cela dit il y a des il y
a des biais et surtout le canal de
l'influence qui est un canal nouveau et
spécifique et c'est cela que nous
essayons de travailler par cette loi
bien on va essayer d'avancer on est
maintenant éclairé je vais vous demander
donc de voter et on reste bien concentré
sur cette amendement de Madame Christol
et ont reçu un avis du coup quel était
votre avis monsieur rapporteur j'en perd
le fil c'est un avis de sagesse un avis
de sagesse sur le sujet qui est pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté